earlier this year we flew out to Dubai
to meet the sartorial shooter and that
episode got over 2 million views because
you guys loved his story well 6 months
later shooter offered to host Us in
Dubai again and we were able to record
our longest podcast with him and safe to
say there have been many developments
with that being said sit back relax and
enjoy this episode of the three Muslims
featuring the sorial
shooter I can talk about something I
haven't talked about before I lost twins
I had stillborn twins fully formed and
at the time I didn't have religion and
so that I couldn't understand why I just
couldn't get why would this happen such
beautiful boys you know sitting there um
and that that drove me away from da a
bit it made me think I'm chasing at the
time I was working so hard it was all
about the money it was all about success
but with all the money in the world I
couldn't get those heart beats to move I
couldn't do it you know what I mean but
now as as a Muslim I think I'd be a lot
better equipped to deal with that sort
of thing because G Allah and again refer
to the life of the Prophet wasam if you
look at how much he struggled and he's
God's favorite then I should struggle
too I think the best and most
sustainable and most healthy heightened
State you can get is not from drugs not
from headism it's from regular prayer
it's from being on the dean it's
surrounding yourself with other brothers
on the dean and working to be better
physically to be better religiously to
be better in terms of your business and
I'm not a guy who's big on the whole
feelings thing if if I don't pray
regularly I feel it I feel something's
wrong any possibility we're going to do
anything with Andrew Tay or trist T
anytime soon yeah 100% we'll set that up
why not I'm not his manager to there um
inshallah spend a few days with him give
him some feedback on how he's praying be
the support that he doesn't have but
okay message is sent a little wouldn't
be cool let's see if he replies on the
pod
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the the three Muslims today
alhamdulillah we are back in Dubai in
the palace with the one and only s
shooter brother how you doing honor to
have you here brother thanks for being
pleas all ours thank you so much for
having
us good to have you here fantastic so
quick update for the record we're
starting at 10: p.m. let's see long we
go yeah sorry I've been I've been busy
guys I apologize wor alhamdulillah so uh
quick update what's what's new with you
what's new so what what are we 6 months
since our first podcast about yeah it
was pretty amazing to see how many views
it got I got a lot of positive feedback
from that and that positive feedback I'd
say is a big part of the reason why I'm
still a public person I've got no love
putting myself out there genuinely like
I I see the value in being a private
person I like the the culture of the
gulf Arabs you keep your family separate
you live behind walls you meet your
friends in the mud list but doesn't mean
they come into the house I get that I
like that more and more um but the
reason why I I continue to put myself
out there is because so many people are
coming up and saying hey I saw that
podcast with the three Muslims it was
amazing all these things the amount of
positive Goodwill that's come back from
that I find really motivating to keep
sharing and keep giving input and again
I'll say for the record my my knowledge
is is is nothing but for some reason you
know G Allah I don't know people like
what I have to say so I'm going to keep
saying it that that's my my take away
from the last keep for shining bro me
accept it from you as well so what what
were some of the things they were saying
what are some of the things they liked
about the podcast um I think a lot of
people talk about the fact that I mean
there's those who are you know
considering Islam and they find it very
useful to see you know and aie talking
about his journey to Islam especially
and we can talk about this my background
I mean Muslims weren't so much the enemy
when I was in the Army but they
certainly weren't the friends you know
so so to go from that side of the
spectrum towards taking shahada is quite
a journey so people I think resonate
with that um from from reverts they they
they like these sorts of conversations
because they're going through the same
process themselves but most of the
support was from the umah was from my my
my Muslim brothers and sisters just
saying reverts bring a bit of a
different perspective and I think a lot
of people find that quite useful because
I think if I'm allowed to say it I think
a lot of people who are born to Islam
maybe they can forget how lucky they are
and how valuable it is whereas when they
see a revert come in with such energy
and and and just just like almost awe at
how much value Islam gives you and makes
you a better person better for your
family better for your community it's
just a win in every sense I think that
can fuel people to get on their Dean a
little bit more that's that's the
feedback I've gotten anyway yeah yeah no
you're absolutely right a lot of born
Muslims whether they're practicing or
not they they they take it for granted
unfortunately the blessing and uh
something that that um we asked Dylan
actually Dylan Madden still working on
him he hasn't taken jihada yet
in we asked him about you and the
biggest difference he's noticed since
you accept Islam he said you seem a lot
more content nowadays yeah I feel more
grounded and I can speak to that so
having having really realized the power
of Islam I've changed all of my future
plans in life for for example I wanted
to move out of Dubai at some point you
I've been in the Middle East for 15
years wanted to retire for example in a
villa in Croatia I I miss that feeling
of of home that I get when I'm in you
know in Australia even though I don't
particularly agree with the politics of
that country now I feel home here I feel
the same longing I used to have for
Australian nature you know the beaches
the mountains that same sense of calm of
grounding I get that when I walk across
the road to the mustard so my entire
retirement plans are changed I'm
retiring here inshallah you know the
cars can go the watches can go I don't
need all of that you know I plan to
retire simple but my my retirement go
goal has gone from Big flashy Villa in
Croatia with a bunch of cars all that
sort of stuff to a nice house that's
easy to maintain and I can walk across
the road to the musjid so my future
plans have changed a lot over the last 6
months and I'm quite clear on that so
yeah to come back to the original point
I do feel a lot more content um I feel
less drawn towards success in daa I mean
I still enjoy the lifestyle I still I
enjoy having businesses that that
provide for a lot of people and enjoy
bringing my people up with me you know
and all winning together but for
sure I don't the Watchers don't have the
same appeal the cars don't really give
me the same kick I I feel more drawn to
to something deeper right which I'm sure
we all know what I'm talking about 100%
so yeah I I feel more content in here
yeah and less drawn to to everything out
there if that makes sense you know
actually it reminds me of a story two
companions of the Prophet they were out
like near the ocean or near some some
some lake at least and they had dry
bread and they were dip it was so dry
they'd had to they'd had to dip it into
the water to be able to eat it and they
one said to the other they said to each
other that if if the kings of Rome and
Persia knew the contentment that we had
in our heart they would send armies to
come and try and take it from us isn't
that interesting isn't that interesting
yeah it's I've had a very powerful
perspective change as a because I've
been I've been I've been practicing I've
been taking my faith seriously I try and
read every evening um I'm having amazing
discussions with with many Brothers U my
Arabic is picking up now starting to
study formally with andalo Institute
that's a good Google search for any
reverts trying to really get the Arabic
tight is that Muhammad Andi yeah amazing
amazing guy he does a good job of
combining educational content with
entertainment as well so I'm really
taking this seriously and as a result my
priorities in life have changed uh my
daily routine is definitely more more
structured I find myself more
disciplined I can say no to a whole
bunch of things which I kind of wanted
to say no to before anyway I never liked
alcohol I can just it's gone now there's
no there's no alcohol in my house either
for a while I had alcohol in my house
for guests now it's gone don't need it
sorry if you want to drink go somewhere
else um in terms of interacting with
women who are not you know family or I
don't need to do that either I I I I can
cut out all Temptations everything
because M at the end of the day dating
and all this sort of stuff it's a low
frequency experience it's a low quality
experience it doesn't lift you up right
yeah so it's I've I've cut away all that
which doesn't serve me and I've taken on
a bunch of new habits which really do
serve me Salah is awesome am I allowed
to say that like it's not disrespectful
Salah is
awesome like it's a lot of people think
oh you become Muslim there's all these
restrictions then there's all these
obligations first let's talk about
restrictions you need to cut away
alcohol it's a poison good you need to
cut away casual sex good look at the
risks involved both physical and in
terms of you know we see all the the
reputational risks that can come with it
and just the wasted energy you know you
need to cut away Pork Man pigs eat human
feces I'm okay with not eating pigs so
all the things you have to cut away
that's fine um and then you talk about
the obligations people might think
praying five times a day is an
obligation if it gives you energy if it
fuels you if it's a way to cut off the
world and just really reset remind
yourself of what's what matters and and
gener very positive emotions and pray
for all the people that you love and
send positive energy towards them and
and pray that Allah subhana wa tala
looks after them that's not an
obligation that is wholly positive so
everything that oh no Islam makes you
restrict things good they're all junk
anyway and all all these obligations you
have to take on with Islam they've all
added value to my life and they've made
me better able to serve my people and my
community and and my staff and my family
I see I see Zero negatives I see
absolutely zero negatives in anything
that I've encountered in Islam which
isn't the perspective that people have
yeah you know they think oh no it's
going to be difficult and challenging
and restrictive it's it's all positive
wow wow and see that's the thing when
you focus on what you can't do you you
and you don't ask yourself why you
shouldn't be doing them you don't get
the value from it that's why in Islam
there's actually a narration of the wife
of the
Prophet where she said that Allah first
revealed Heaven hell belief in God
before he revealed you know don't have
sex and stop drinking alcohol she said
if he had first revealed stop having sex
stop drinking alcohol they would have
said we're not going to leave these
things cuz they don't see the value in
it but as soon as you understand that
God knows what's best for us if you do
what he says then you'll live the best
kind of life that's kind of summarizes
what you were just saying I like that
but people don't look at it in that
sense and I think even without faith and
I'm talking to everyone out there who
still engages in Hedonism everyone knows
alcohol was junk everyone knows it's a
poison that only leads to bad things
every time someone's in a fight in the
street alcohol every time you know every
time there's an argument Al like it
doesn't help anything it does not add
value to life in any way and when when
you talk about headism everyone who's
engaging in h headism even without faith
they know it's junk anyway so really
what are you doing you're just cutting
out negative habits it's nothing but
positive man well I think it's something
like 90 or 95% of all crimes are done
under the influence of alcohol bro just
take that in they did a study in
Princeton University and they basically
concluded after asking you know men and
women on campus the main finding was
that most people like I think 95% of
people don't actually like alcohol they
they think it's disgusting but they
drink it because they see everyone else
drink it and they think they should like
it if that's not the most group think
sheepish mentality you feel junk the
next day and yeah I'm so glad you know
inshallah the Tates are out soon I'm so
glad I can say to Tristan nope I ain't
touching that drink and he's he can't
argue with it this time cuz yeah that's
a group thing right and with when you're
with the lads is what you do and oh why
did I do that but then you do it again
Islam gives you that nice firm nope I
ain't doing it cuz it ain't healthy it's
not natural it's not useful for me so
it's a very powerful thing speaking of
Tristan I remember this one thing that
he mentioned in a in a podcast he's like
reverting to Islam is not something you
do it's something that's done to you
right something that happens to you on
the path of your spiritual journey so
this being said how has your
relationship with trist changed after
you were a Muslim oh to be honest I
don't think it's changed that much I
mean we we're we're strong Brothers it's
just I now know that I have a reason to
not drink with him so no it's I've got a
lot of love for the brothers and and
nothing's changed there I we can talk
about them as well if you want at some
point we can go into that but I'd like
to hear from you guys like where's your
where's your journey I mean we talked
about your plans we talked about the
fact that you have incredible potential
and and some steps to really get that
out there how's that
going now amazing alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah thank uh thanks to your
connections and all your help
alhamdulillah we spoke to amazing people
got and the thing is I don't know what
it is about our podcast or I think it's
maybe because we're younger guys we
chill whoever we go on the podcast
they're so open about like almost
everything Tam conon we got stuff out of
him that he's never said like
islamically speaking religiously he
never said on any podcast same thing
with Ahmed B chba same thing with like
Hamza zorus you just aldah lot comes out
so it's it really is a blessing you guys
are good at what you do
alhamdulillah make us the way you see us
I was going to say the same thing mean
so all these reasons you mentioned
before is is this a part of the reason
why you added a Masjid to your new
Taylor shop oh wow very excited about
the Masid in the Taylor shop um I think
yeah to to summarize why I've I've
jumped into Islam so deeply um as a look
I was 40 when I reverted I'm 41 now um
learning new things when you're very
busy man at at 40 is a chore right it's
oh I have to make time to learn this I
have to make you know put aide time I
have to clear my
schedule learning Islam has not been a
learning about Islam and getting my
Arabic going again has not been a chore
in any way and that's a bit of a rare
experience for me cuz first of all it's
funny I thought I understood Islam a bit
before practicing man I know nothing wow
it's it's almost like when you start to
study Islamic history and and the depth
of the the Arabic language and the depth
of the Quran and the Hadith and so on
it's like a a huge ocean and and you
thought you understood it but then you
see the ocean is just endless and I mean
I don't care how well you swim you're
not going to cover that ocean you just
have to accept there's so much out there
but the more that I
uncover the more energy I have for more
study and that's a very unique
experience as a guy who didn't have time
I didn't really have have time for
reading before I read every evening now
pretty much without fail it's part of my
daily routine um it's gotten me
motivated to learn something new again
that I just didn't have that there's
zero obligation involved I love it and
and people talk about the the the daah
High um I I I think this is a permanent
State I think if you objectively look at
the depth of the guidance in Islam and
the the pure power the Deep intelligence
in the system for life that is Islam you
can't help but be excited about it cuz I
don't care what I mean people say you
again a lot of people say they found
Islam at their worst times I found Islam
at my best times that materially da wise
there's nothing I could have wanted more
this has added so much value and it's
made me a better man more disciplined
more able to resist temptation more
present and caring with my family
members more committed to really helping
on a human level my staff to to to level
up and to do well Islam has made me a
better person when already especially
from external perspectives I was already
winning man what is there not to love
what is they not to be excited about
this is not a fading daah High I've
discovered a certain truth and I'm
running with it inshallah for you know
as long as I can there's so much to
learn I'm actually scaling back on a lot
of my businesses on three of them in
particular so that I have more time for
my faith I want to it frustrates me
every joh my prayer when I can't
understand all that's being said you
know it frustrates me that when I read
the Quran it's so slow so I am actually
saying no to money actively and saying
no to take on more contracts and more
tasks and so on so that I have more time
to focus on on on my faith cuz that's at
this stage of life that I'm in that's
where the real deep feeling of
satisfaction comes from it's not from
more stuff or more wins business-wise
it's from you know learning more about
this ocean of knowledge that is Islam
yeah so what would you say your
objective now in life
is it's funny I think becoming a
practicing Muslim and praying regularly
has gotten me a lot more in in touch
with with caring for my people CU every
time I pray at the end of it I I say may
Allah subhana wa taala protect and care
for my family members I think of all my
family members my staff I think of my
staff I think of my brothers I think by
regularly multiple times a day thinking
about the importance of the health and
well-being of the people in your life it
has made me more empathetic and more
caring so to be honest brother I don't I
don't ask for anything for myself when I
pray and in terms of my goals in life I
don't really have any personal goals
alhamdulillah I have enough money I have
enough experiences accolades whatever
the main thing for me now is lifting up
my people it really is and that's that's
what excites me especially when you know
my brothers I've had a lot of brothers
revert which I think is incredible it's
very exciting we pray praying together
with your brothers tell me that you're
hitting the gym with your brothers and
praying with your brothers tell me that
doesn't beat any hedonistic experience
on the planet tfold 10-fold absolutely
and I've I've done the the headism and I
did it pretty well you know like I put
in time and effort to that sort of thing
back in in my younger years I get so
much more satisfaction cuz again ask
anyone who knows me when they say hey
let's catch up what do I suggest all
right come let's lift and then let's
walk to the Masjid that that's it I'm
having my meetings now while lifting and
going to the Masid what did we do when
you guys arrived lift Y Must
steak that's life man there there's not
much more to it so yeah my my main push
in life now is to learn more about Islam
CU I see that it's the truth and I see
the power there and to to work as as
well as I can and be as disciplined and
high output as I can staying in that
high output state which I love to talk
about um so I can best look after my
people that's that's what drives me I've
got enough man I've had enough
experiences I've got enough toys this is
about what I can do for my people you
know keep you st fast bro this being
said what are some lessons that you've
learned that would be useful for other
revers out there all right so certain um
resources I wish I knew about at the
start of my revert Journey so first I
think learning how to pray accurately is
absolutely key I was using a book and
YouTube videos that's okay but there's a
refer uh a website that I only found out
about a few weeks ago I wish I'd known
earlier it's Salah companion. us and
it's this little graphic and it shows
you what to do and shows you the words
it's perfect so Salah companion. us is a
great one for reverts and also alquran
Alim you know that the Quran the really
big one every single word is translated
because in in most qurans you'll have a
sentence and then you in in Arabic and
the sentence in English that doesn't
help you if you're trying to learn
Arabic and learn each word at least the
way I learn
in that alquran Alim it's a big book
it's by my bed I read it every night
every single word is translated so you
can actually improve your Arabic and
learn word by word while you're reading
the Quran so they're two really good
resources um but to be honest and I
don't know whether this is a bad thing
to say when I was first studying Islam I
couldn't really connect with the Quran I
found it a bit too deep what helped me a
lot was listening to to discussions from
my devout Brothers I found disc
discussions from my brothers who could
interpret and and show me the deeper
meaning behind certain parts of the
Quran that was my Gateway into then
reading the Quran and really
understanding it myself so I'd say to
reverts find yourself practicing
brothers and talk to them about Islam
and also consume content from guys like
you that to me almost makes the meaning
in the Quran a little more accessible
especially early in your revert Journey
where where some things in the Quran you
might not really fully understand does
that make sense yeah no absolutely 100%
I think even like some born Muslims when
they when they get back into it these
are stories and things they've heard
many times um to understand like Allah's
wisdom is not something that's simple
right so sometime and especially because
Islam is a whole system so to understand
one thing you have to understand it
sometimes in conjunction with another
thing like if I say I eat with my right
hand doesn't always make sense till I
tell you you know I wipe with my left
now it makes sense dirty things with my
left clean things with my right so
alhamdulillah Islam has a whole system
it's it's something that you really only
understand when you get the you know the
full picture not missing the the forest
for the trees as they say you but you
said you wanted to talk more about the
spiritual higher something that you felt
yeah I mean it's I don't I'm not into
the spiritual thing I'm not into the
hippie stuff but I have to admit that
there are very strong emotions and high
energetic States from being a practicing
Muslim um and again I think everyone's
chasing a higher state right why do
people take drugs is to feel a higher
state why do people chase Hedonism is to
feel a higher state you can get that
high State through healthy means like
going to the gym everyone knows you get
a good work out in you feel high
afterwards doing an ice bath you feel
high afterwards for me if you're praying
regularly and if you have that knowledge
that you are on the dean and you doing
the best that you can and you're
surrounded by other brothers on the dean
that to me brings a
very it's not like a a sort of fast
burning high it's a very slow
sustainable drawn out satisfaction that
you know you're living well you know
you're living the way you're meant to
live as a human that to me is a
heightened state which I I greatly seek
and a few times I've been traveling and
I haven't kept up with Salah as much as
I wanted to or I've been away from a
Masid for a while I've felt that that
I'm on the straight path energy fade you
know people talk about that your Iman
being like a battery and the battery can
be full or the battery can be empty I
feel that very clearly um I think the
best and most sustainable and most
healthy heightened State you can get is
not from drugs not from headism it's
from regular prayer it's from being on
the dean it's surrounding yourself with
other brothers on the dean and working
to be better physically to be better
religiously to be better in terms of
your business that state where you're
surrounded by Brothers all on the same
path all living the best they can be as
humans are meant to live as we know
that's the best heightened state that
you could hope for as a human and if you
can maintain that for the majority of
your Human Experience you're going to be
a better person you're going to have
higher output you're going to make more
you know you'll be more successful in in
you be more successful you in I think
that's the ultimate height and state and
I got to say I'm I'm I'm hooked on it
man if if I don't pray regularly I feel
it I feel something's wrong like it's
very interesting it's very and I'm not a
guy who's big on the whole feelings
thing but I when the call to prayer goes
I get I feel my chest going oh like and
if I miss it I feel I feel that I'm not
being the best man that I can so the
best height and state you can
get thankfully we've been told how to
live we've been told how to do it follow
the system that is Islam and and enjoy
that sustained high output heightened
State free of distraction free of of of
Temptation that's the way to live
powerful absolutely bro so this being
said what advice would you have to
someone that's kind of considering reing
to
Islam um I mean I think if it's a
Westerner there's a lot of negative
stereotypes to get through a lot of
negative stereotypes uh Islam is a
religion of the poor Islam is an
extremist religion Islam um is is
somehow misogynistic I mean it's first
you need to address all of those so
first of all the one about you know
Islam being a religion of the poor many
of the the sahaba the prophet Companions
of the Prophet were very successful
Khadijah
[Music]
um perfect sorry I should be better by
now she was a very successful business
woman um when you know so obviously it's
there's nothing wrong with success and
and as long as you keep because I've
read up about this as long as you keep
Islam in your heart you can have wealth
in your hands especially if you're able
to better look after your people and
gives a cat and so on as long as you're
not attached to money as long as you
don't worship it as as you know which a
form of shk there's nothing wrong with
being successful as a Muslim the next
piece that it's it's somehow um an
extremist religion man spend some time
with Muslims they are the most kind and
compassionate and genuinely hospitable
people that the men I respect the most
take their faith very seriously and
again they will treat you well because
every interaction every moment they feel
accountable to a higher force that on
the day of judgment they will have to
answer for what a perfect way for to be
able to trust somebody if they really
feel everything they do they're being
judged that's going to be a good person
so this whole idea that Islam is somehow
tied into extremis spend time with
Muslims that's the best way to dispel
that spend time with good Muslim
brothers and you'll see it's a very
compassionate very caring very
supportive religion uh the last piece
that it's somehow
misogynistic how many strong figures do
we have in Islam of women I mean we
could talk about
Asia and and how what she achieved and
how how she led in in a
battle it's she she like she narrated
hadiths there's a woman who achieved so
much how could it be a religion that
suppresses women when you have hundreds
and hundreds of years ago women in
leadership roles who were very very
strong very well respected very capable
and this whole thing that the the hijab
is somehow suppressing women I actually
used to think that I'll admit that when
I was in Australia I thought oh no that
that's suppressive but now understanding
if a woman chooses to protect her
modesty and and shield herself from
unwanted attention I respect that fully
good honor I think it makes sense Islam
is a very practical religion you cannot
stop men staring at women you can't do
it especially if those men aren't
religious it's it's you not it's not
realistic to think that so if a woman
chooses to Shield herself from that
unwanted attention I think it's a very
healthy choice in the same way I'm
walking down you know a poor part of the
world I'm not going to wear a platinum
day Date Rolex bit of a flex I quite
like this watch anyway but it's just
sensible like I'm not going to if I
don't want unwanted attention from
people you know to who would Target me
for my wealth I'm not going to display
my wealth in the same way if a woman
chooses not to have unwanted attention
from strange men she should have the
right and and she should be proud of
that choice to protect herself from
unwanted attention so all of these myths
about Islam and the negative
connotations people attached to it if
you actually look into it none of it
checks out none of it none of the
criticisms of Islam that I've looked at
in any way match the reality and this is
a guy who used to be in the military
back when the war on terror was the
whole thing right like I grew up I
learned FY and and Dari language of Iran
Afghanistan for you know to deploy it's
it's and this was again it wasn't
thought of as the enemy but you know
Muslims were thought of at least as a
minimum dangerous as as a minimum you
know the propensity to be extremist and
all these sorts of things I came from
that far negative view of Islam to 15
years later taking shahada and having a
positive impact on every area of my life
and and enjoying it so much that I'm I'm
open that's why I'm sitting in front of
cameras again I don't have that much
love for cameras I I I got a bit of
online notoriety through being
associated with the tap Brothers but for
years I was behind the scenes I had no
love with the cameras and I I'm happy
with that I went public with you guys
that podcast to speak for the T Brothers
they're out now so I probably won't do
that much public stuff apart from if
we're talking about Islam I'll take
every podcast I can CU it is that
powerful the benefit for people in terms
of their individual growth as people and
the benefit they can bring to their
communities their people you cannot
falter you cannot question it if you
practice Islam in a sincere way you will
be a better human you have a better
Human Experience you'll be better able
to look after your people your community
your family it's so positive that I I
just I can't stop talking about it and
and so it's that's why I'm happy to have
you guys here that's why I'm happy to be
in front of a camera the world needs to
know about this like especially in the
west people don't understand people do
not understand the the benefits of of of
adopting Islam and practicing it in an
Earnest manner people got no idea and it
took me 15 years in the Middle East to
really figure it out if we can speed
that up for other people you know
inshallah that that that's a huge
blessing to give to someone it really is
if anyone who can bring someone to Islam
you were you were bringing such a
positive change to their life on so many
levels it's it's a beautiful thing it is
brother you talked about not being
attached to the D not being attached to
materialism while flexing about my watch
yeah
yeah how would you you know what would
you say to someone to be able to keep
the D in their hand and not in their
heart M it's a tricky one for a long
time I was very money focused um first I
was driven because I was you know I was
poor I was angry at how poor I was and I
channeled that energy into getting money
from there once you get over the money
it's sort of the status and experiences
and all these sorts of things but at the
end of getting money you realize that
getting money doesn't at past a certain
point doesn't give you know there
there's diminishing returns if you're
worth 5m there's not that much of a
difference if you're worth 10m like
you're you're still eating the nice
steak and living a good life like at a
certain point there's no reason getting
more unless it's just an ego thing you
know I mean I I can understand some
people they're building businesses
they're providing you know bringing a
positive impact and so on but just
chasing money you're going to get sick
of it and so you can chase money as hard
as I have and get that money or you can
realize H yes I'll get enough money to
live well and look after my people but
beyond that it's not necessary and it's
not not necessarily fulfilling like
money past a certain point is not going
to change your life that much get your
money right to the point where you can
look after your people but from there
focus on what matters like look I've got
more money than I ever dreamed of what
is my ultimate day it's prayer training
hanging out with my brothers eating good
steak may may maybe you know maybe
there'll be another training session
maybe we'll play some chess or or read
it's the it is the simple things and it
is time with your loved ones that
matters more than any money in the world
so I think a lot of people they'll put
so much emphasis on
money then finally the end of that road
is you realize you know what it doesn't
really bring I mean it's a necessary
element to living well but it's don't
don't don't worship it don't don't you
know faith is real money is just an
aspect of in my mind practicing if you
practice your religion well and you you
maintain that discipline living with
that and you've got good Brothers around
you the money will come I think that
should be the order focus on being a
good man and being disciplined the money
will come so then what about the
opposite end where you have the the
brothers who they try to say oh no we
shouldn't focus on money at all we
shouldn't have any money whatsoever I've
actually had some of yeah I've had some
people um within the um criticizing me
about about being a bit Flash and fair
enough I'm I'm I'm a bit flash on
Instagram and so on the the amount of
positivity the amount of people saying
hey this inspires me to do more to
achieve more I me again I came from a
welfare family which was a mess I went
the amount of times I went to bed with
breakfast cereal as dinner like it was a
lot right I I grew up as as pretty much
as rough as you can get in in a in a
first world country very blessed to be
born in a first world country and now I
have Financial Independence and so on if
I can show what's possible in the same
way the Tates they're a great example
they grew up real rough like they were
in in homeless shelter at some point and
now they're you know incredibly wealthy
I think it's a very positive thing so I
think again it comes down to the neara
your intent if you're showing off a
flashy lifestyle to inspire others to
show them what's possible I think that's
a positive thing um but the key thing is
and I'd say to any detractors who say oh
no he's too flashy and so on I'm not
attached to it you take the cars take
the watches it's not going to change my
life at some point I I'll give it away
or auction it and use the money for
something useful like as long as you're
not attached to success in the da and
and you understand what's real and what
isn't and and you have Islam in your
heart I think it's a good thing to be
successful so that you can look after
your people so you can give Z cut in in
a you know impactful way and to anyone
who says that oh no you shouldn't chase
money and success in daa I think they
need to read certain parts of of our of
our you know the Islamic text out there
a little closer because even the call to
prayer it come to success no like it's
you're being called to success and to me
when I hear that it's like the more I
pray the more disciplined I am the more
I resist Shayan and these things the
more successful I'll be to me being a
good Muslim and being successful are
tied into it each other I don't
understand this whole to be a good
Muslim you need to be poor or or or sort
you know there's some of that like can
you guys speak to that cuz I have seen
there's a bit of that sort of negative
attachment yeah and it's it's completely
it's completely wrong even from the
perspective like if you want to bring
people to Islam let's say you have a
huge demographic of people which there
is a huge demographic of people who look
up to the rich who aspire to be like the
rich so if you have someone who's rich
who accepts Islam people going be like
wow maybe there's something there as
opposed to a poor man is like a homeless
man I'm a Muslim it's like unfortunately
in real life that doesn't mean to much
to people so even from that perspective
it helps but to speak about it
islamically Allah the prophet he said
the strong believer is better and more
loved by Allah than the weak believer
and strength isn't just like muscular
strength it is also muscular strength
but it could be Financial strength
intelligence wisdom um um you know
strategizing many different things and
many of the sahaba as you mentioned were
Rich there was one companion um I forget
the name but um he traveled and he did
Hijra to the land where like the Muslims
were
and they the Muslims wanted to help him
they're like you know let us give you
some money get you started he's like
just point me to the marketplace he went
to the marketplace started doing
business and trade and he ended up being
one of the wealthiest people if not the
wealthiest person in in in the whole
city Subhan Allah manb afan the the you
know one of the greatest sahaba
companion of the Prophet peace be upon
him one of the wealthiest people and he
contributed a lot to the battles that
the Muslims fought okay I like that and
to me that's the thing I I think in its
Essence if I'm allowed to say this is a
recent revert Islam demands especially
of the men to pursue excellence in all
Realms it really does you need to be
physically strong you need to be able to
give zakat to your to your community you
need to be able to provide for your
family well you know you're held to
account yeah that goes in alignment and
that supports trying to be successful as
long as you're not attached to money as
long as you're not worshiping a Sher as
long as you realize that everything
inona is ultimately meaningless and
we'll be left behind I think Islam wants
us to be successful as people so that we
can be most positively impactful for our
families community staff and so on yeah
yeah and something something that Simon
Simon Says quite shout out to your
brother something that he told us
recently I'm glad you guys met he's an
amazing guy he's amazing something that
he taught us recently is the word which
means man the root word of it it comes
from like um basically it means like
something that's moving progressing it's
tied to like the leg you know the legs
carry you forward they progress you so a
a real man is someone who's always
progressing
and isn't that interesting again there
again we have the depth of meaning
within the Arabic language within the
Quran when are you most satisfied as a
man when you're making progress now I'm
glad I never caught a crypto pump I'm
glad that every step up I made I earned
I mean I wouldn't mind wouldn't have
minded crypto pump but anyway I'm glad
that each one of these little levels up
where I went from it was the most
amazing thing to be able to buy a $1,000
car incredible to now I have I don't
know 10 plus cars like it's
it to to make those little steps up
that's where the satisfaction comes from
right and and all are of course Allah I
don't I don't claim to have to have
earned it by myself this is all
blessings from Allah subhana wa tala but
to me it's it's very clear that
there's there's no reason to not
be fully on the dean and fully
successful at the same time I I I really
think it's there's no reason for the two
to get in the way of each other and
making progress as a man as you've just
said that is when we are most satisfied
as men that is when we're most fulfilled
so of course within the language you you
find that meeting in there it's
incredible it really is and there's this
whole narrative that Islam equates to
being anti successful I don't know where
it comes from man and a lot of people
they they shame you for Success so it
almost normalizes the state they're in
it's like this whole people that are
morbidly obese not because of a medical
condition just cuz they just don't you
know like to hold on to themselves they
like to let go of themselves they'll
create these body positivity movements
just to shame you for wanting to care
about your physique interesting I think
it's a Pity I really do I I think for
Islam to be more broadly accepted by
especially those who didn't grow up
around it we need to get rid of as a
noral if I'm allowed to say it again as
accepting my my the limitations of my
knowledge we need to get rid of this
connotation that Islam is only for poor
people we need to get rid of the we need
to let people realize that if you want
to be disciplined if you want to be high
output if you want to have those traits
on a day to-day basis which correlate
with success Islam will help you with
that I really think that's a message
that needs to be put out there I really
do absolutely 100% and something that
one one uh brother reached out to me
saying is that we need to focus more on
the Oneness of God um
because a lot of people have an innate
belief in one God they don't they don't
believe like three in one they don't
believe millions of gods naturally
intrinsically we all believe just one
God worthy of worship how he just feels
right it feels natural it makes sense on
a deep level 100% and at the end of the
the day like when you have stress of
life and I've I think everyone's
experienced this when you have stress of
life you know you can't handle
everything yourself that's why we have
teams that's why we Brothers it's why we
systems that's why we we're social
beings but when there's something that's
out of like everyone's control you have
no effect on it you leave it up to Allah
he's the one who's all powerful who's
all wise and any problem you have he can
he could take care of it for you so a
lot of these people that live in the
west and they're so focused on the D and
there's so many things that they just
can't get a hold of like If Only They if
they just believed in God prayed to God
like even once a day a lot of that would
be stripped away from them indeed indeed
and that's what I love about and again I
think there's a very deep intelligence
within Islam everything makes sense if
you look into it deep enough like the
the the the action of suud of
prostrating yourself getting down on
your knees and and saying to to the
Creator to use you know more generic
terms I I I acknowledge your greatness
and I thank you for everything that's
very humbling I think part of the issue
in the West is the ego is so catered to
hey make sure you get the I phone that
matches the color of your personality
all this nonsense right whereas if you
are regularly throughout the day
reminding yourself I am literally
nothing compared to Allah subhana wa
tala and all I have is is blessings
from well beyond me and my capabilities
and again in terms of the bad things if
something happens to me okay go that's
bad this is part of my path my journey
my struggle to learn if we want to talk
about a difficult life look at the life
of the
Prophet man lost lost close lost mom and
dad at an early age lost lost family
members was was beaten was kicked out
had attempts on his life look even
Muhammad who was chosen to narate the
knowledge that we have now in the form
of the Quran so you could argue one of
God's favorites look how much he
suffered you know I mean so and when you
have this knowledge and you understand
okay if I'm if I'm facing an obstacle
sickness something challenging this is
God Allah this is is part of my life
path having that knowledge that there's
something bigger than you man I don't
know how people live without it if you
really want to go through life as a as a
Godless Westerner thinking you're going
to wrestle through everything and
anything that happens it's you and
anything that happens positively it's
it's you and and just think that your
ego is controlling the universe man
that's pretty ungrateful that's pretty
care that's the the root of the word
right and in gratitude and isn't that
another thing like even that word kaffer
I I didn't know that it was tied into
UNG gratitude but if you think about it
a kaffer someone who thinks no no I'm
I'm the center of the universe and I'm
doing all of this that is deeply
ungrateful like it all makes so much
sense I'm loving getting back into the
Arabic language and I'm studying in a
lot more of a deep away now the dep the
depth of that language is incredible it
was actually Simon who told me I think
and I'm going to butcher this but he
said that English has I think it's maybe
a couple of hundred thousand words in in
the vocab I think he he told us recently
I think it was like 12,000 words or
something like that okay something like
that okay whereas Islam has sorry um
Arabic has millions of words it's just
the
depth you cannot compare yeah there it
is I think there's aith where the
Prophet mentioned something like oh is
the state you know such as the state of
the believer when a Calamity befalls him
we say alhamdulillah when something good
happens to him we say alhamdulillah so
this being said can you pinpoint
negative effects you don't have to you
know mention them by name but anytime
you had negativity in your life things
that the moment you were like why am I
going through this but they actually
contributed to the success you are in
today tricky um I can talk about
something I haven't talked about before
hopefully don't get emotional I lost
twins I had stillborn twins fully formed
and at the time I didn't have religion
and so that I couldn't understand why I
just couldn't get why would this happen
such beautiful boys you know sitting
there
um and that that drove me away from da a
bit it made me think I'm chasing at the
time I was working so hard it was all
about the money it was all about success
but with all the money in the world I
couldn't get those heart beats to move I
couldn't do it you know what I mean but
now as as a Muslim I think I'd be a lot
better equipped to deal with that sort
of thing because G Allah it's not the
right time now thankfully though I
believe you know my kids were born and
they're healthy have two kids who were
healthy but um dealing with that sort of
thing without faith who difficult brings
brings you to your knees whereas
interestingly enough when I was working
in Iraq one of my staff his 2-year-old
from a heart heart issue and was brutal
obviously we took care of you know paid
for funeral everything he was back at
work the next day I couldn't understand
it I said brother like take as long as
you need now he said no it's helpful for
me to be here I want to be here and this
is all the will of Allah I couldn't
understand at the time if anything I
I'll be honest I thought man that's
crazy he's just lost a child he should
have a few weeks off a month off but he
was like no this is the will of Allah he
and obviously he was just praying
regularly and he was on his Dean isn't
that interesting as a as a cfer as a as
a non-believer losing my kids took me to
my knees as a human like was was the
worst experience of my life by far and
I've been through some bad experiences
here we had a religious man who lost a
2-year-old someone he'd spent years with
so even if we look at objectively even
more negative than losing you know fully
formed stillborn twins born without a
heart rate so on he was at work the next
day and he on a deep level I mean
definitely sad but he was grateful for
the experience he was grateful for the
years that he had with his son and he
viewed that it was Allah and he just
kept going isn't that a remarkable
comparison of dealing with severe you
know obstacles in life so and that's
that's something I'm very grateful for
with Islam I really believe now that if
I was to get sick or if something
terrible was to happen I can accept it
on a deeper level because I don't think
this is just my ego running the shop I
understand that there is a higher power
that is dictating certain struggles
certain life paths and again I refer to
the life of of the Prophet wasam if you
look at how much he struggled and he's
God's favorite then I should struggle
too because that's what life is about if
Allah subhana wa tala has given us
obstacles and challenges and sicknesses
and losses that is that is Allah that is
part of our path and we should be
grateful for it we should say
alhamdulillah and if you're living in
the west without God you don't have that
that frame that mental frame you are
less mentally resilient as a result wow
you know what's beautiful the fact
that when we come into this D Allah puts
our soul into a physical body right and
then we will be tested throughout this
time and then we are sent back to Allah
but when someone dies in the womb or
maybe I forgot there's a certain age
before they are actually being held
accountable if they die before this time
they are immediately automatically
accept into J straight that's the most
beautiful thing yeah so may Allah reite
you with your your lost kids man I mean
I mean man I I want to get up and hug
you bro no man it's tough man but on man
as a as a revert yourself can you relate
to some of these things too that after
Islam when a Calamity befalls you you
immediately if not even immediately you
can attribute it to okay maybe there's a
greater power yeah's a greater plan 100%
because the same way as you brother like
I I've not been in this position so I
can't speak from experience but my
sister she had a child and he only got
to 7 months old and then he passed away
brutal mate brutal and I was like you I
was not Muslim and I remember when this
happened I was asking the question why
like God if you're real like why is this
happening and I couldn't understand you
notice in movies there'll be murders
there'll be rapes but they don't show
the death of a child in a movie cuz it's
just so brutal I didn't know that
actually about the director entry to
thank you it's beautiful
right
bro sorry don't mean to bring in
emotions no bro listen at the end of the
day we're humans and even the Prophet
The Prophet Muhammad sallahu alaih
wasallam like you think this man didn't
cry he used to cry when he would think
about the the fact that there was going
to be so many uh brothers and sisters
that he was never going to be able to
meet did I get that
correct is that correct yeah he was he
was asked like you know who are these
brothers you like this Hab would ask him
you have us and he's like no these are
the people that will come at a time when
they can't see me but they believe in me
awesome amazing that's us yeah but don't
don't ever say don't ever say sorry for
man I have got more emotional since
practicing Islam I I'll admit to that
it's crazy right heart yeah it's a real
thing this softening a heart thing real
man like and it's interesting in in
Western culture especially as an Aussie
you show emotion they they're going to
call you a certain word a certain word
that denotes certain Haram activity
let's put it that way but what I'll say
is man like and I I can admit to this
regularly in prayer I'll feel emotional
regularly and it's it's it's not a
sadness it's it's not a happiness it's
just if anything is a deep gratitude I'm
just so grateful to a found this lamb
that it actually hits me in a way that I
feel emotional and I've I've talked
about this before numerous times men
have been crying in in the mosque I've
noticed it numerous times and the man
let's face it Muslim men pretty
masculine you got the Beards you know
they're usually pretty strong there're
about it but they're also feeling
emotions I think it's I think it's a
beautiful thing I think it's a more
rounded thing I think it's quite a
secure thing like I think if you're a
man who can cry out of the beauty of
your connection with your faith I think
that's that that shows you're quite
secure as a person I think it's it's a
nice rounding of masculinity as opposed
to this this tough guy who doesn't show
emotion I don't think you should cry if
things are tough in life get on with it
no one cares I don't think you should
cry if you're having a hard day or
you're stressed but if you're crying due
to you know the loss of a loved one or
due to your connection with Allah
subhana wa taala I see no shame in that
I I think there's nothing wrong with
that at all there's this thing that I
heard a long time ago that says when you
see a man cry it's not that he's weak is
that he's been strong for so long that
he's just finally like letting go in
that moment yeah I think I'm getting I'm
getting a bit soft in my old age but
it's good bro it's good your heart is
getting softer it's all because of Islam
and you had mentioned this earlier that
uh for you you don't feel like it's just
as high as a Reaver it you feel like
it's an actual like it's a it's a
lifestyle now like in your life 100% I
think it cheapens it to call it some
kind of high I've entered a
a a an energetic high output level where
there are zero distractions there's zero
headism there's zero temptation to say
no to all of it it's all junk every day
is discipline and good men around me men
who I can really respect men who I can
welcome into my home I'm very particular
with who come comes into my home
nowadays I'm I'm getting more and more
golf Arab with my time here man like
most people I'll meet him in a coffee
shop or the mjus like they don't need to
come into my house you know but whereas
when a man is a is a on the dean and I
know he's got his life together and you
know he's disciplined and he treats his
family well and he's he's a good man
these are the sort of people you want to
be around if you're practicing Islam
earnestly you're going to gravitate to
more of these sorts of people like the
people in your life will be a higher
quality when you are taking your faith
seriously it's quite remk
every area of your life improves when
you when you practice Islam in in a
committed manner every area it's
remarkable how is it typ cast as a
negative thing I I just want to talk
about you know the atheists and the
criticisms that people have of Islam
they're like oh yes but you need some
religion to guide you you should be able
to figure out yourself sorry what you
think as an individual being on the
planet for what 30 40 years you know
better than a system of life that's been
around for centuries that was narrated
between 610 and 632 Common Era you know
like you really think you know better
than that all right fine fine there's a
reason why you're called ungrateful
careful I get that but also even to the
atheists or the people who think you
know Islam isn't bad tell me if they
were practicing Muslims for a month they
wouldn't be better people they wouldn't
be more based and and regulated in terms
of emotions they wouldn't be more
disciplined and resisting temptation and
that which is bad for their health they
wouldn't feel more accountable to be
better in serving their family serving
their Community tell me that everyone no
matter what level of life you're at no
matter what culture wouldn't be a better
version of themselves if they weren't
practicing Islam in a committed manner I
haven't seen anyone counter that
argument cuz I I can show it from my
lived experience it's real it's powerful
yeah and and many even the sahaba they
went from being like the you know
craziest most badass people too the best
Muslims the best companions um and they
had fun together too they were ping
together as as men like living life it's
people don't realize like the stories of
the sahaba they're pretty based it's
like it's like if I'm allowed to say it
Lads having fun with each other joking
conquering building like if you want to
talk about men's Natural State the way
the sahaba live together to me that's
that's the dream if you get get Brothers
around you like that and just you know
leave a positive impact on the universe
that that's that's what this life's
about right there sorry to cut you off
no worries that's a great Point 100% I
never thought about like that to be
honest the way this Hab interacted subh
Allah may Allah grant us that may Allah
make us like them I mean um something I
did want to say on on the point of it
would make Islam makes people better I
think it's it's very similar to how
certain foods you put in your body will
have certain effects on your body if you
eat trash you're going to have symptoms
of a trash body and if you eat healthy
you're going to have the symptoms of a
healthy body I think spiritually with
correlation to knowledge and what we
observe and what we listen to and what
we remind ourselves of what we surround
ourselves with this is spiritual food
that we're putting into ourselves or
emotional food putting into ourselves so
if you're only reading garbage only
seeing garbage only thinking garbage
that's going to reflect in how you feel
and how you live life and in your
day-to-day interactions how you treat
others but when you put you know the
remembrance of Allah you know as Allah
says in the Quran indeed with the
remembrance of Allah the heart to find
ease and contentment you're going to
walk through you're going to just Glide
throughout life you're going to be more
Blissful than you would have been
without God there it is and there's a
real Bliss there I remember when I
started praying regularly I felt like I
was diving into an ocean of calm if you
will if you know if that sort of analogy
is cool but then I read was it a Hadith
or in the Quran somewhere about the idea
that there's a river and you go on
purify yourself in the river whether
it's in
um yeah and it's like they were sort of
talking about the experience for me that
is is prayer you you're you know through
woodoo you're washing yourself of or G
washing yourself of impurities to
prepare yourself for something sacred
and then you going and you literally
your heart is at rest you can turn off
all the work meetings and all the this
is Du and all that and you really just
hit the reset
button I I don't know look I'm not into
hippie stuff again but there is an
energy energetic benefit to Salah which
I'm still only just beginning to
understand but I see the I see the the
positive impact on my life like it's
almost like you know spiritual modern
day spirituality they're all just trying
to replicate Islam man oh you have to
meditate well that's what Salah is we do
it five times a day so or you should say
positive mantras that's what Salah is
you know what I mean like we are asking
to stay on the straight path to resist
temptation or you you know and the
health stuff or you should fast well
that's what Ramadan is like there
there's so much wisdom in in how to live
out your Human Experience within the
routines within Islam I see again and
again that there's one um religion uh no
one spirituality thing I used to read
about it it's called hot poo poo or
something it's from Hawaii and they say
certain things routinely to make your so
make your life better they say uh I love
you please forgive me and a number of
things and they say it regularly as
mantras what are we saying for allahar
Subhan Allah all these spirituality
methods they're all just watered down
weak attempts at Islam like I see it
more and more it's it's it's funny so
everyone's looking for meaning in their
life everyone's looking for purpose
everyone's looking for structure there's
one that's been written a long time ago
which is superior to everything else out
there and I'm a guy who tried a lot of
things I tried the yoga thing the taii
the meditation I've tried this all cuz I
think there there are benefits from
these things Islam is just a better more
efficient more powerful way to to bring
about these benefits can you relate to
the fact that all these things like
meditation chanting yoga it's almost
like you're putting yourself as the
center of the universe whereas in Islam
you know Allah as the center of the
universe and you're nothing and many
times it's like just knowing this you
know in Islam or anything else even on
your spiritual journey just Allah is
here I'm nothing mhm knowing this
positioning you get anything in life
Allah will bless you exactly and I think
that's that's the main reason why in the
west you know people are are so unhappy
and just living such empty lives it's
because the the ego is running unchecked
and I think I think that's a fallibility
if I'm using that word correctly of The
Human Condition is the propensity for
our ego to think I am the center of the
universe I'm what matters I'm
controlling all of this that leads
directly to a very Str ful and very
unfulfilling life we need to Humble
ourselves to to be fulfilled Islam is
the most powerful way to do so yeah ego
I was actually going to make a point
about ego that when we have ego we feel
like we need to keep up with it we feel
like we need to keep up to a certain
standard that I'm the man I'm the big
boss on whatever it's a lot of work and
it's a lot of the time it's ego you a
person can't afford so it's so stressful
cuz they can't live up to it but when
you remove that from yourself you're
like I'm just a dude alhamdulillah you
know that's it alhamdulillah when you
say can't keep up with it is it like
those is like rented cars rented women
rented 100% all all all of that stuff
man I feel it's so funny like I spent a
lot of time around celebrities um and
very wealthy people you know throughout
my
career I don't respect someone who's
very wealthy or very famous or or any of
these things if they don't have faith
nowadays I just don't I just view them
as lost people I think they're just
chasing false gods and they're living
lives that are ultimately meaningless
and a lot of the time they're very
deeply unhappy people very insecure
there's drug habits or there's you know
running through many different women
habits I I I think what western Society
views as oh wow amazing Rich famous
whatever I don't really respect that
anymore I have more respect for the
brothers that I see when I go to the
mased every day who are taking their
faith seriously and also funnily enough
the brothers who I see every day in the
Masid they're a lot more fulfilled as
people they got a much more positive
glow about them they're a lot more
enjoyable to talk to the West it it
glorifies all the wrong traits in a
person nowadays it really does yeah you
know what I think even in the west they
have this spiritual center called a
mosque I think they should just go visit
just go mosque and see how Muslims are
just literally go walk in and say listen
I'm not a Muslim I just want to see what
you guys are about I promise inallah
it'll be the best experience you've ever
had in your life and the support from
the um is amazing like Islam does have a
bit of a perception as a very strict
very sort of intimidating
religion every single individual who
I've talked to has been nothing but
supportive you've seen the shelf of
books they're all gifts I've had people
don't even know send me gifts just
saying hey welcome brother I want to
help you like the amount of support you
get when you revert especially if you're
blessed to be living in a Muslim country
is incredible the support from the um
it's anything but strict take your time
you know do what you can let me know if
I can help it's it's the opposite of
what people expect what you're saying ju
reminds me of Hadith where the Prophet
mentions none of you will truly believe
until you love for your brother what you
love for yourself nice that's a yeah
it's a beautiful one I like
that you know speaking about
Salah
it reminded me of the conversation we
were having with a and he showed us this
video where they did a scientific study
on how Salah affects the brain oh wow
nice have you seen it no I'd be very
interested in that though cuz I've been
thinking about these things myself been
reflecting on this neologist yeah it's
crazy because so they have two examples
the first example the brother performed
Salah rushed okay very quickly nice y
the doctor gets the two examples the the
results and he says in here there's no
real change the brain it shows the two
examples the the scin exactly the same
now he performs Salah again but this
time with a more Earnest intention right
is so huge so which is the presence the
focus being in tune with the prayer and
he took his time they even like turn the
lights off and everything let him just
continue praying in there by himself
then they did the scan and the before
and after before like the brain like all
the things was all like disorganized
crazy and and then after everything was
aligned perfectly aligned symmetrical it
was the most beautiful thing ever and it
shows that Sal is something real Salah
is awesome it's so awesome like before I
reverted I thought H having to pray five
times a day that'll be a chore I get
excited I'm happy walking the mosque
it's just it's it's such an energetic
boost if you're looking to be a high
output man and and be the best version
of yourself to take care of your family
and your employees and your community
Salah supercharges that it's anything
but a chw it's anything but an
obligation now fuder haven't quite
cracked that cuz I usually finish work
at 3:00 a.m. but but I'm attempting to
scale back on work so I can I can nail
that but again when we talk about the
Deep intelligence of Islam why fud
because naturally we should get up early
in line with the sun and we should get
to bed early in line with the Sun for
the best you know for your hormones to
be balanced for your recovery again
everything that is in Islam has its deep
reason why if you look into it now I
need to stop going to bed at 3: I need
to work less I need to be healthier
getting up for fuder is my reason to be
healthier again in every way Islam makes
you a more healthy more balanced more
mentally resilient person it's it's so
powerful and it's this being said man I
had some questions about the Tade
Brothers do you have any updates I know
everyone's wondering like what is going
on with them they're out of prison we
don't see videos of them yeah they're on
Rumble but what's going on with them so
yeah the brothers are good um they
they're I mean they're they're mentally
you want to talk about mental resilience
that they've been through a lot in life
and they they they are they practice
what they preach right they talk about
being mentally resilient they talk about
taking challenges and and being in a
state of combat and still being positive
and still being disciplined that that's
them they're in prison without proper
food and no gym they're still training
there's a reason the tape brothers are
famous it's not from saying mean things
it's because they are so disciplined and
they are role models for men who want to
be disciplined and become better
versions of themselves right so they're
fine um I remember the first time I
think the podcast that we did was the
first time I went loud you know really
properly talking in in their benefit I
did one with fresh and previously but
just with us I don't really need to
speak for them anymore they're out of
prison they can speak so I haven't been
doing all these podcasts and things
anymore even though I've been invited
because they can speak for themselves
and they're better at it than me but
from my perspective as as a guy who
cares about them deeply as brothers
they're doing okay I think I'm more
concerned for them than they are to be
completely honest I'm deeply concerned
with how ridiculous this whole
situation is in that again without going
to Too Much details I'm not a lawyer I
don't represent the T Brothers
officially I'm not in I'm not even like
I don't understand what's going on
legally I'm not read in on these things
but I do know and I referred to this in
the first podcast without giving details
that the two main
complaintants are far from credible in
this whole case the first one has a
history of making false allegations
against men saying I've been kidnapped
saying look that was was consent during
the ACT but afterwards I've decided it's
not consent I'm going to have to take
this to the authorities unless you give
me this or this she's done this and it's
on record there are court cases against
her in the US where she's been extorting
men and making these claims and the
leaks that have come out have her family
saying why are you doing this again in
her own chat records that have come out
through through all these leaks from the
prosecutors so anyway the first person
and she already had only fans before she
came over to Rania she already had um
like these sugar daddy websites where
you get rich men to fly you out she
already was working on like a sex
hotline this was not an innocent person
she and she was in Romania for 6 days
booked into a
hotel yet she claimed she was human
trafficked it's just such nonsense look
the Tes have said plenty of bad things
on the internet I get it if I'd only
seen the bad things that they said I
might be offended myself but the reality
is if we're going to talk about what
they are charged for that first
individual has a history of lying and
manipulating and it's on record funny
how the uh the journalists don't cover
that piece right and the second
individual who's the main complaintant
in this whole thing was working as a
stripper in the UK met and and this is
all out there I'm not breaching any
trust here Matt Andrew said to him hey I
want to make money online instead of
working and there's a specific amount of
money I want to make can you help me
with that he said yeah fine come over
she was working getting paid able to
leave the house whenever she wanted had
a phone or you know normal no
restrictions on her her movements and
also knowing the tape Brothers the
second a woman says anything disloyal
doesn't want to go they're just like all
right go then that's their whole policy
I've seen the Tates so many times have
to say to a woman all right go and just
they cut them off completely the Tate's
main challenge is getting women to leave
it's not restraining them or doing
something you know deceptive or against
them U and so that's the second main
complaintant someone who was already a
stripper and who asked Andrew to make
her money online yet we're going to
pretend these two people somehow did
something against their will and they
were used as forc
labor the first one flew bus business
class over and was in Romania for 6 days
and was in a hotel and already had an
only fans account how is that human
trafficking so that's my perspective on
this whole thing and this whole
preventative detention in Romania you
can be held for 6 months without charge
in Australia I think it's 24 hours UK 24
hours us 6 months they can hold you that
is some communist error outdated
nonsense and unfortunately if a certain
person in the Romanian system as we see
with the current prosecutor has like a
fixation on someone or has has an agenda
then they can abuse that system and
that's what you're seeing with the Tes
the Romanians must know cuz they're
investigators they must know that the
credibility of the two main complaints
is nothing is a joke yet here we are so
the allegations are completely from
uncredible sources and it's almost like
they're they're guilty trying to be
proven innocent by default it's wild it
is wild the process is the punishment
right and as I understand it the other
complaints two of them say we're not
guilty in any way I believe one of them
has a degree in Psychology and she's
saying look no one's manipulating me I'm
I'm wanting to work and I'm getting paid
and everything's fine but no no you're
brainwashed you're a victim bra isn't
that terrifying yeah isn't it terrifying
so yeah the two main complaints they
have no cred credibility others are
saying we're not actual victims like
it's there are so many holes in this but
I don't see the the journalists and the
investigators covering that at all it's
really quite unfortunate so and if
anyone wants a proper breakdown of the
lack of credibility of these complaints
Candace Owens did an amazing breakdown I
think a video was called um Candace
Owens examines the Andrew Tate victims
so have a have a Google of that watch
that if you want to see just how far
from innocent helpless victims these
women are if anything especially this
primary complaintant she is the
manipulator she is the one who is
extorting she is the one who is
committing the crime and I have to
believe that that will show in in
history because man just have have a
look at her it's ridiculous it's it's
almost comical how much of a lack of
credibility that Source has yet the
Tates are still constrained they're
still having their freedom taken away
it's it's remarkable and look I get it I
get the haters Tates have said some
controversial stuff Andrew used that as
a medium to become you know world famous
but guess what I was there for 5 years
when the camera's are off I've never
once seen him raise his voice with
anyone I've never once seen him be
disrespectful I've seen the women in his
orbit they're enjoying life they're
having fun this main complaintant was
making sexy Tik toks in the house not
Andrew or Tristan Tate she was doing it
for herself the video show them coming
back from a mall unloading Handbags and
luxury goods from the back of a car
they'll flown business glass and put in
a hotel that's trafficking it's utter
Madness but I don't see any coverage of
that side of the story anywhere so I'm
deeply concerned about how the reality
doesn't matter I'm deeply concerned
about the how outdated the Romanian
system is I think it's absolutely
terrifying if they want to get you they
can that um that quote show me the man
I'll show you the crime from Stalin's
head of security
man that's what's happening the Romanian
authorities know that the credibility of
these two main complaints who are the
only ones really pushing it is absolute
zero Beyond zero but the Tates are still
held because show me the man I'll show
you the crime it's communist error
nonsense it's it's it's concerning man
I'm I'm more concerned for those
Brothers than they are they they're fine
they'll handle anything and they'll keep
being them and they'll keep winning
regardless of what happens to them but
I'm deeply concerned at how twisted this
whole situation is we can't we can't
expect perfect Justice bro and this D
unfortunately this is the reality and
all we can do is pray that they do get
Justice in this D but if not in the and
there's something I I want everyone to
know that you can be nothing in the eyes
of the Dy you can be worthless you can
have no reputation and you have no idea
how Allah is speaking about you to the
angels bro with what high rank that
you'll have but you could be everything
in the D bro you can have it all but
you're not going to be even looked at on
day of judgment interesting I like that
that that yeah that's good to know it
really is but again I've said it before
I say it again I I put my everything my
my 100% conviction on the fact that the
Tates would never do these sorts of
things because again I've seen the women
in their presence man I'm a Former
Intelligence professional and I've
worked in in the world's most dangerous
places I'm pretty good at reading
situations reading people I'm a trained
investigator not once have I seen any of
the women in their orbit and let's face
it there were a lot they're popular guys
not once have I seen them be
uncomfortable not once have I seen them
be scared they well taken care of they
you know flown around private or you
know business class they're given gifts
the women in his orbit are well looked
after the idea that he's somehow forcing
someone to do something it's just not
real it's it's and I've seen it I've
been there I've been around them for 5
years yeah I've spoken to a lot of
different documentary makers guess what
they don't include my
content I've spoken to a lot of
journalists guess what they don't
include my content they don't want
someone who is a credible source again
I'm not an objective Source I love the
brothers dearly but I I'm happy to go on
record and I'm happy to swear by my
faith and and by my my honor as a man on
what I've seen these are good men who
take care of their people and yes
there's a lot of talk but again all
right every gangster rapper who says I'm
going to shoot this going to shoot that
they're not doing it or if they are
they're in prison right like it's there
is such a thing as building a character
and yes the Tate said a lot of
controversial things that's not what
they're being charged for they're not
being charged for saying bad things on
the internet they're being charged for
human trafficking and forc labor with
women who ask them to help make money in
an industry they were already in it's
nonsense mate it's nonsense it's wild
and anyone who's online at all who you
you look deeply into their life enough
you're going to find things you're going
to find things and you can make a whole
case whole story show me the man I'll
show you the crime exactly what's happen
in Roman and I I genely believe Muslims
have an obligation to defend him at this
point because we believe innocent until
proven guilty if there's some crazy
evidence okay you know let's let's see
it but as Muslims we are obligated to
see both sides of the story Allah says
in the Quran this is from Allah he says
when you hear I'm going to paraphrase
when you hear news from an untrustworthy
Source you have to confirm it you have
to verify it that's fantastic assess The
credibility of the source I say that all
the time nobody can look into these two
main
complaintants and think that there's any
credibility whatsoever in what they say
yeah it's it's it's it's comical how
clear it is especially the main
complaintant is a Serial liar serial
manipulator what she says she has a
modus operand she has a
proven tendency to make up these stories
and these lies to try and exploit men
and that's that's what happens you know
what's really interesting if you look
into it properly she at one point wanted
this whole thing to stop she like no no
I I take it back I don't want this to
happen but the man she was talking to no
I'm involved in the embassy we're making
you know like it's there's so many holes
in this yet the brothers are still
constrained it's it's it's terrifying F
man it's absolutely remarkable it really
is you know what this shows this shows
that it's actually real that there is
groups of people who are at the top that
they try to make it seem like it's not
real but it is real they're at the top
they have an agenda and there is
something going on that we as laymen
were not seeing 100% 100% the um the
investigators involved in this case
there is no way they haven't seen how
uncredible the two main complaintants
are yet they still continue on as if
it's a credible manner that means
there's an agenda of some sort very
clear so tell me this whole case was
started with these Witnesses and then
one of them wanted to basically withdraw
the whole thing and stop and they
continued even though the witnesses
check the video out check Candace Owen's
video out she goes into incredible
detail uh it's bro it's laughable it's
absolutely laughable yet where's the
coverage of that everyone just
conveniently ignores that yeah that's
another thing when when I find when
media focuses too much on something when
there is some kind of other side um or
or like maybe related people doing
similar things that they're not talking
about you can't help but wonder why yeah
for real no I think it's deeply
troubling and I think the takeaway for
men nowadays is avoid avoid Z it's the
risks are not worth a return avoid
having women in your house who you do
not know and trust and and view as
either wife material or your wife you
know what I mean like don't engage in
sex outside marriage and and also be
very very slow and very careful in
carefully assessing who you allow into
your life because very bad things can
come of this it's it's remarkable that
watching how many men have had their
lives upended because of the the the
women they allowed into their lives be
very careful who you're let in that
that's men nowadays especially in the
west I mean Romania isn't even the West
you need to be ultra careful with who
you led into your life and again Islam
solves that don't get naked with a woman
unless you are you know with a contract
under the law under your faith taking
care of her in a way that's that's clear
and Halal and clean the risks are not
worth a return it's wild I don't even I
mean I don't want sound misogynistic I
don't let women in my house that I don't
know you're not no it's not happening
never and I've got the full CCTV system
as well doesn't help you as we've seen
in the Tes case so women do not come
into this house that that that that are
strangers to me it's just not a thing
wow I think every man needs that same
approach you know what's crazy though is
that there are certain Muslims out here
that are literally throwing Andrew under
the bus and Tate as well even though
Tate's not Muslim but they're throwing
and in the bus Tristan yeah huh what you
said anate as well did I say that yeah
trist yeah Tristan
Tristan but they're throwing them under
the bus and they're saying Andrew is not
a real Muslim because of these things
when they're trying to say that he's a
fake Muslim that he's using this for uh
just to have uh the Muslims on his side
and all of this stuff okay to that I'd
say his H his home is the most most
heavily Orthodox country in the world
Romania right now he enjoyed visiting
Dubai but Romania was still his home you
really think if you were just doing it
strategically you would leave the church
and join
Islam it doesn't make sense and also
sure you can say that there's support
that comes from the um when you become
Muslim but there's also a lot of hate
that comes from people who aren't Muslim
there's a lot of downside as well I mean
I've experienced some of that myself we
can talk about that if you want it's not
all positive um so yeah that's just it's
not real now yes he's not going to the
Masid every day but if he was here in
the Middle East perhaps he would be I I
I I can bet with conviction if he was
here he would have already gone to Mecca
and Medina would would you gone on umra
it's if he he was around other Muslims
and if there was a mosque nearby and if
he had Brothers he could pray with I'm
sure he'd be able to advance in his path
as a Muslim a lot more than he is able
to now with his Liberty restraint people
are forgetting this you know yeah we
spoke with Tam KH about this and he was
saying imagine you just accepted Islam
and after a few weeks you put him in
jail yeah for real and he said that
these people they're being so
hypocritical of him and so judgmental
because they're they're thinking one
thing when in reality this is this is it
over here you know and we had a brother
that we met in in Mecca may Allah bless
him he didn't have these bad assumptions
but he said that he saw a video which
the tape Brothers had put up which was a
reenactment of what it was like when
they were in prison MH and they put a
toilet in the house and they did 24
hours of what it was like and in this
video he said he saw that Andrew wasn't
praying at all in the thing and then to
that I thought to myself hm how many
more Muslims are thinking the same thing
they see this like oh isn't Andrew T
Muslim why is he not praying but then
again think about what what uh Tam KH
said I was about to butcher his name AA
bless the brother but he said imagine
being a Muslim or becoming a Muslim and
then just going straight to jail I think
three weeks not even right bro I don't
even think he learned how to fully fully
pray he he there's no one around him can
teach him that the thing with t cuz I
said to him like brother show you're
learning Arabic show you know he's he's
memorizing some lines of the he said no
I'm not going to do that I said what
about showing you praying he said no I'm
not going to do that cuz there's always
going to be people who are hating on it
and criticizing it he's the thing with
Tate is he's so driven to be perfect at
everything he won't like he doesn't play
pool he doesn't touch pool cuz he's not
really good at it you know when when we
when I taught him how to shoot we we'd
spent hours with him perfecting
something otherwise he doesn't want to
be seen to be doing it like he would
never do something that then people
could criticize and who's he had with
him to to pray with
he told me he prays and I believe him
he's not the sort of guy needs to lie to
a brother um but if he's not confident
in doing something he's not going to
give the haters a gift by praying imp
perfectly and having everyone say oh
look at this that that's his mindset so
I think that explains that one there
what's crazy bro it's like you're damned
if you do you're damned if you don't
there's going to be Muslims at his
throat if he was praying but they're
going to be like why is he not moving
his finger why is he not doing this if
he wasn't restrained and he was here in
Dubai we'd be in the mustard every day
sure and we would have gone to Saudi I
mean he's told me how much he wants to
do these things people are quick to
forget that he is restrained in his
Liberty who who are criticizing him yeah
and Muslims who who have this kind of
perception they need to ask themselves
what do they really want do they want
him to start praying cuz they're not
going to get him to start praying by you
know yelling at him and the haters are
strange I pray for the haters brother
genuinely I've had some haters come
after me as well um say say nasty things
about my kids and all sorts of weird
weird Behavior but genuinely I feel
nothing but compassion for them because
if you we have a limited time on this
planet right if if you're using that
time to sit behind a keyboard and throw
hate and weird allegations at people
that's a pretty sad existence so
genuinely I genuinely not all the time
but I I often pray for the haters and
hope I hope that they find more meaning
in their life I hope they find better
people around them I hope they find
Faith cuz man they're wasting their time
on this planet we our time is finite you
know what I mean cuz the thing is too
with the haters doesn't impact anything
in the real world they they're genuinely
just wasting their time writing nasty
behind a keyboard that that doesn't
bring any impact whatsoever what a what
a waste of a life it's very strange
Behavior I don't really understand
haters in that sense it's it's weird
Behavior yeah often times they're also
projecting something that's like an
insecurity within them like there's a
thing it's like you spot it you got it
so if you're just out here doing most
yeah projection exactly but as with
everything like a lot of people like
they get all I got some friends who are
you know on the internet and they get a
bit Fired Up by the haters not Tes they
don't care about haters um the best way
to deal with haters is just to to win at
life you know live be on the dean take
care of your people who cares what
people say only Allah subhana wa taala
can judge you and if your people are
looked after and you have you know good
good men around you you're building
businesses providing for many families
people can say nasty things on the
internet it doesn't affect you I think
people need to realize that it's not
real speaking of being on The Dean I
noticed recently you've been on the dean
show how was your experience meeting
brother Eddie well first of all I
managed to avoid rolling with him he's
he's apparently he's a weapon at BJJ I
had a few people warned me they're like
if he asks you to roll with him just say
no that's an impressive man like he's a
he's a good father he's a leader of his
his community he he's very driven
towards what you know the da and and
he's building mustards and he's got an
amazing BJJ setup this is what I mean
the men who I respect the most take
their faith very seriously that is a man
you can instantly trust instantly
respect he's having a positive impact on
the world I mean he's he's he's
ferociously capable as as you know in a
violent sport but he's the most gentle
and respectful and calm guy you've ever
met this I said it before one of the key
reasons why I reverted was the men I
respect the most consistently are are on
the dean they take their faith seriously
and our man from the dean show EDD is a
perfect example of that that that is a
man you can respect and the more you
know about him the more you respect him
so yeah that was great I really enjoyed
that discussion I'd love to I'd love to
support what he's doing more and more
I'd love to host him in Dubai incredible
he's got my full respect wonderful what
a wonderful man really with this being
said do you think there's a possibility
cuz I know a lot of the viewers are
going to be just flooding the DMS with
this any possibility we're going to do
anything with Andrew Tay or trist T
anytime soon yeah 100% we'll set that up
why not I'm not his manager to everyone
out there yeah we don't like these
comments saying when are you going to
get Tates manager back on yeah no it's
um you try managing the Tates my
goodness the two most strong-minded
people on the planet um 100% 100% oh I
can message him whenever you want and
and um yeah I'm sure he'd be open to
that I'm sure he
and you know what inshallah spend a few
days with him give him some feedback on
how he's praying be the support that he
doesn't have you know what I mean like
it's yeah I think that'd be really cool
I I would be very happy to try and and
set that
uping
awesome that would be amazing honestly I
think I think he'd really welcome that
too cuz he was visited by and obviously
no shade to these people he's vised by
Patrick B David Candace Owens you know
which are there for which actually
that's a good question which Muslims
thought to go visit him I don't I
haven't heard of any requests W in we're
the first in let's do it honestly let's
do it I'll message him now if you yeah
let's do it let's message him live on
stream easy easy be dope man honestly
this discussing with you and Tam KH
really just put into perspective like w
I feel so sorry man I feel so bad it's
like obviously like alhamdulillah as you
mentioned he doesn't let it affect him
but the fact that there are all these
people who are not emotionally
empathetic enough to understand that
this guy had 3 weeks before he's thrown
in a dungeon for like 3 months straight
he was he was in prison longer than he
was a Muslim basically yeah or a free
Muslim I'll say and it's I don't
understand like look I can understand so
I'm just sending him our last episode so
I can see what what you guys do um I
don't understand like people are so Keen
to to hate the tat so quickly
um are they forgetting okay look some of
the stuff the Tates say back in the old
days was negative guess what they've
changed people evolve people get better
I thought also as a Muslim your sins are
washed away once you revert right like
what happened to that to the the people
criticizing um
but yes they've said some bad stuff on
the internet they will even Tate himself
in his final message on Rumble he said
what I said to an audience of tens of
thousands obviously is very different to
what I say when having an audience of
millions they are cognizant of the fact
that it's their responsibility to speak
well I would suggest that the haters
have a look at the Tate when the
camera's you know when he's speaking
without the the show and Tristan as well
these are very very articulate very
insightful very motivational men who
bring a massive positive benefit there
are there are so many examples of people
saying I got my fitness together you
know I got my money right A lot of
people saying I was considering suicide
but I found your messaging now improveed
my life there is so much positive impact
from the words that the Tates have have
have put out there why they're popular
and the haters are just not
acknowledging that they just just go and
look at any one of Tate's videos and
look at the hundreds if not thousands of
positive comments underneath everyone's
just neglecting to realize or to notice
that there's a positive impact on people
again that's why Tate both of them are
are so popular the supporters of Andrew
and Tristan Tate if they live by what
what the brothers preach their lives get
better they're more disciplined they're
healthier they're okay with wanting
masculine achievement in masculine
excellence in a society that's saying no
no no going to the gym is a micro
aggression all this nonsense that's why
the Tes are popular i' I'd urge the
haters to do a little bit of
investigating as to the positive message
and the positive impact that the Tates
have had
Subhan but okay M just sent there a
little wouldn't be cool let's see if
your replies on the Pod we'll see that
beol that
be this is a little bit kind of off not
really off topic but a little side note
here I don't think that it's a
coincidence that Andrew Tate became
Muslim y I don't think it's coincidence
that you became Muslim
because look how disciplined you guys
are and think about when when a man is
disciplined what does he do he starts to
get rid of the things that restrict him
that hold him back in life and he starts
to add things that allow him to progress
and move forward in life and that in a
sense is a purification process and you
can't you can't help but but understand
that when you are purifying yourself in
this way you're also purifying your
heart and the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam has said that
in the pie in the body there's a piece
of Flesh that if it's pure then verely
is the rest awesome I love it I love it
I love this talking the heart yeah it's
if you're the Tate's main message is
pursue masculine excellence in all areas
of life and that's why you know I became
such good friends with them because I
was doing the same you know independent
of them of course being around them
helped me level up to a whole whole new
level of discipline these guys are
ferociously disciplined but if you a man
who every day wants to be a better
version of himself and have hence have a
more positive impact on his family on
his community all these things you are
going to end up with Islam it is
inevitable if you if you are if you're
hard is sof it if you objectively
reading the the the you know the
landscape of of The Human Experience
it's inevitable to end up with Islam
because you are a better version of
yourself with it than you would be
without it it's and so all these people
like oh yeah Tates chose Islam for for
clout it's like I would have bet my my
life on the fact that Andrew would end
up with Islam years before he accepted
Islam because it's it's inevitable and
especially when you look at Traditional
Values when you look at stoicism when
you look at men should be strong should
be disciplined you know this is what
Tate's about there's correlation there
so he was always going to end up with
Islam and I hope and I pray that he can
get his freedom back come over to the
Middle East and get more time around
brothers who were on the dean so he can
continue his learning and become even
better as a human imagine if he was able
to practice Islam with the support of
Brothers every day imagine the insights
that he'd come up with with with his his
ability to to Really Channel information
and Analysis he's I would love to see a
very very very religious and in the
Middle East supported by his brothers
Andrew I think that would be a very
powerful positive impact on the world in
are they currently still on house arrest
so they've got something called judicial
control as I understand it and they they
were confined to the Bucharest area I
believe but I think maybe now they're
allowed to drive around the country I'm
not again I'm not really caught up with
the legal thing but taking Tates to om
anytime soon that's not going to happen
they need to get cleared from this mess
in Romania first they really do Allah
give them strength yeah for real I pray
for them every day man I really do may
Allah grant them Justice the Justice you
know that they deserve and may Allah
spent out their freedom and unite them
with uh you know they love the Wes and
you know anyone who they haven't been
able to see um I know the beginning SP
it must have been very hard when they
were in jail not able to see their
family their kids yeah brutal man do you
have any idea how long this this might
take I've got no idea man all I know is
that the the Romania system is is
apparently very slow so it could take
many many months just to have the trial
done that's horrible yeah yeah um
something that that came to my mind
recently I I mentioned a lot of the
samei on the last few podcast just
because we talk about very similar
topics alhamdulillah but um um when I
look at you and I look at the tap
Brothers um Allah you guys are very just
very kind people you know like just very
outstanding and and and very kind people
genuinely and uh obviously I don't know
Andrew or Tristan but from the the
testimony of people who have met them
different people I've never heard one
person who met them who stayed with them
in their house who said a bad thing
about them and it just makes me think of
this Hadith the prophet he said that the
best of you in Jah which is like before
your Muslim are the best of you in
Islam I like that yeah and that's the
thing that's the reality and that's why
I felt compelled to give up my privacy
and speak openly about the Tates I've
been around them for 5 years they are
nothing but generous nothing but caring
of their people if anything sometimes
they're too good I'm like guys there are
too many people you don't know in this
house oh no you're just paranoid relax
like I'm I am Mr professionally paranoid
I was urging them to be less generous
with hosting less generous with hey yeah
bring bring whoever you want let's go on
this holiday like I was the guy who was
sitting there saying I don't know about
this one I don't know about that one
they're good men they're caring in men
they're supportive they take care of
their people they really do take care of
their people so the idea that they're
somehow you know the these these hidden
nasty guys and and none of their Inner
Circle even noticed any red flags it's
it's nonsensical man it's just not real
so talk about yourself giving up this
privacy with social media so social
media is something that it's very
difficult to maintain your Nia you're
correct intention into while you're
doing it a lot of people get into just
flexing putting on a self image a fake
image a lot of other people are like you
know what I want to do it to inspire
people so how is your relationship
social media been ah it's love and hate
bro like it's funny I I greatly enjoy
the positive feedback I get U first of
all the only reason I'm known on social
media is Tates you know I I didn't even
have private uh sry public Instagram I
think before them I had like maybe three
or four post on my Instagram before them
you know and it just it all blew up from
being around them that's the power of
the Tate brand if you're around Andrew
and Tristan Tate your brand will blow up
funny that that might have something to
do with why women were asking hey can
you help me make money online anyway
maybe they're capable marketeers or
something so that's the only reason I'm
even on social media and the only reason
I started doing podcasts was to speak
for them at a time where they couldn't
speak so I'm not naturally inclined to
being public on Instagram you know um
but I'm also motivated by the fact that
I have people come up in public all the
time and they say hey man this really
you know I heard this message from you
keep doing it it's really positive so
I'm doing it because of that positive
feedback and I believe it's my duty now
especially as as a Muslim to share what
I've learned and inshallah help guide
people to our faith will help people
stay
on doing the little that I can but bro
like I also don't like social media I
think it brings out the worst in people
I don't like being it's funny like I'm
I'm very grateful when people come up
and give me positive feedback it happens
pretty much every day but at the same
time I don't like it you know what I
mean like it's I I'm like thank you
brother I'm grateful but at the same
time I'm like ah this is weird you know
it's it's not my I'm a security
professional it's not my natural state
to be all over the internet but it
happened naturally Allah I'm not going
to do a whole bunch of podcast and try
and grow following and do all this stuff
I don't care but when it comes to
podcasts when there's an opportunity to
speak about the beauty of Islam and to
to help educate people and correct the
false narratives about Islam I'll do
every one of those that I can that so
that that's my Approach now it's to
inspire others to yes you can be
successful and yes you can have a
powerful faith that adds value to your
life at the same time I view that as
what my brand is about and and by the
way if you want to buy clothes I have a
TA shop you can't having having having a
big following is is useful if you're
trying to launch a business now the
tailor shop for me Isn't So Much a
money-making thing but also I'm okay if
it is and and the Instagram will help
with that so you know there's positive
and negatives I think to social media
would be the answer the one thing I
would say is I consume very little I do
very little reading of social media I do
very little of liking of posts what I'm
doing is producing and that's something
Tate talks about he says have a look at
your relationship with social media are
you producing it in a way that adds
benefit to your life whether it's money
or positive impact on society or so on
or you just consuming and flexing for no
reason so I I think less consumption on
on social media more how can I use this
platform in a positive way whether it's
building a brand and making money or
putting a positive message out there I
think that's the way to go you two know
that he named his company custom made
reality right especially last time he
was talking about you know creating your
custom made reality so I think that's
such an appropriate name bro yeah thank
you man I just launched custom made
reality racing team as well I got to
stop buying car I bought three more cars
this week I got to stop
is it hang out with Tate you'll end up
buying a bunch of cars I tell you you
see you see what's possible you know you
see see someone who grew up literally
from the ghetto now has 30 40 cars in a
Bugatti it makes you think wait a sec if
I work really hard and I push and I I
create businesses and just live in that
high output state where you're just on
all the time I can I can have a bit of
fun as well it's a very positive thing
sure wonder what color is your Bugatti
what color is my ducatti Bugatti it's
green
it's funny it's on my motorbike I have
what color is your ducatti I I rocked up
the other day to fill up the uh the
other one over there the the street
fighter and the guy putting in the
petrol he said what color is your
ducatti oh I get it Andrew Tate I'm like
yeah nice the reach of Tat's brand is
remarkable it's before he was the most
Googled man in the world now I think
he's legitimately the most famous man in
the world and yes they're going to go
through you know more drawn out trial
stuff and and some hardships they're
fine man they are built for combat
they're ready for this if anything they
embrace it
and after this when it's all done watch
how powerful the Tate brand is in terms
of a positive impact on society it's
going to be a beautiful thing it's just
a question of how long this this
absolute nonsense trial and it's its
repercussions take to to you know play
out I'm sure the late em T would be
proud of them wow it's yeah that was an
interesting man in itself yeah there
there's I think he's his the the the
Tate's father raised them in a very
conscious way to make them very high
output very capable very very different
men and it worked it's quite remarkable
it really is yeah incredible case study
there something that they clearly have
is good Brotherhood and in Islam Allah
says in the Quran indeed the Believers
are brothers Fant so I would like to
talk a little bit about Islamic
brotherhood you mentioned you know the
mass the the mosque when you go you see
these brothers you see how tightly knit
they are how how caring they are for
each other what is it about Islamic
brotherhood that stands out to you I'd
like to answer that by by talking about
this is another example of the deep
intelligence in
Islam the fact that when you are praying
okay so it's good to Pray by yourself
it's better to pray with your brothers
it's better to pray in the mosque you
know this is all by Design I swear it's
when you are standing shoulder toosh
shoulder with your brothers in the
mosque that is the natural state of man
we're meant to be together as a pack
with some sort of mission that's when
you're most fulfilled that's why men
love the military so much they're there
with their brothers and they're on a
mission you know whether or not it's a
healthy one and whether or not it you
know damages just them and other people
is a different story but the natural
state of men is to be rolling with the
brothers disciplined on on a mission
focused that is replicated every time
you go and pray in Islam and so I think
it's I think it's a beautiful thing and
another example of why Islam really is
the best way to live out your Human
Experience Islam understands the power
of Brotherhood and most men especially
in the War Room which which is an
organization I'm very proud to be a part
of ignore all the bad press you know
there nothing but positivity in there
and it's 100% Hala nowadays there's
there's no there's nothing Haram in the
war yeah it's all Halal nowadays which
is great which I'm all four um but the
the war room is we have a lot of guys
who com in and they say the Brotherhood
I have in here has changed my life I'm
more disciplined I I feel more connected
I feel I have more support before I was
lonely I think Western Society
especially I saw a Harvard Business
Review study that said Executives in
their 40s have like 1.6 friends or
something it's quite miserable I think
Western Society isolates you from
Brotherhood Islam brings you towards
Brotherhood that's because that's where
men are most powerful and most fulfilled
on a deep level so again I just see that
as yet another example of how Islam is
pushing us to live in a way that is most
natural and most optimal in terms of our
our our frequency and our our lived
experience and our the the the state
that we live in throughout our days yeah
and you can really pinpoint the
principles like it all comes from
principles in Islam we have the these
principles of like you mentioned loving
for your brother we love for yourself
you don't have that in the west the
closest thing is treat others Tre all
that garbage listen if anything there
The Keeping Up With the Jones where
neighbors compete oh he's got a nicer
car than me like it's it's some sort of
competition it's the opposite of Allah
say in the Quran you should compete with
one another in good good I like that see
isn't that wonderful and that's the
thing before Islam you don't even
conceptualize the fact that Shayan
exists you don't even conceptualize the
fact that you have Shayan Jin whispering
in your ear yeah if you are on the dean
your main goal in life is to be a good
virtuous human that doesn't get
conceptualized in the West it's that
powerful so that's why I respect people
who are on the dean more than anyone
else cuz on a day-to-day basis it's not
I want to get more money it's not I want
to get more status it's I want to be the
most virtuous human I can be because I
know there's a judgment day coming I
think it's a beautiful thing it's
amazing absolutely absolutely and that
opposed to individualism you know I want
to get my money up you know don't waste
my time all the stuff it's it's very sad
what a boring and limited existence and
that's why people are so depressed
because we're social beings we need
something called social solidarity you
know even if we come together in the
thing that is is causing us pain And
discussing it together working through
it together that will give you that
social solidarity that you need and it
will Elevate you in life like nothing
else that's why I respect Andrew and
Tristan as people who grew up you know
as non-muslims having that Brotherhood
and always sticking together and you
have to ask yourself and I think it'd be
interesting to hear from them or you if
you know would they be where they are
and as successful as they are now if
they didn't have each other oh I they
they speak to that all the time and and
the way they've set up up their life
where they don't live with women they
live with
themselves and they they're coning that
masculine frame of Max training Max
output Max discipline where they check
each other hey man you know you're
getting caught up on this or you're
letting that slip that is how they built
who they are is the power of Brotherhood
and masculine accountability and and
again that's what's replicated in their
organization the war room it's it's a
very powerful thing and we see it within
Islam we we see the idea of you should
have strong Brothers around you you
should have Community you should be
close to your family you should have a
good relationship with your father in
the west there's no messaging that tells
you to maintain good relationships with
your parents there's definitely no
messaging that tells you to have strong
capable stoic men around you it's quite
the opposite in the west you should just
sit around the house and and essentially
let your woman boss you around that's
kind of the norm that we see in Western
relationships it doesn't lead to
fulfillment for either party and men
have gotten comfortable nowadays being
home Discord PlayStation network not
really going out there so how how do you
recommend they go out there and find
these brothers what a mess well I think
first of all you need to you need to
question now look I'm not going to try
and say I understand how men should live
and so on but I think every man should
question how healthy is it to be around
a woman all the time genuinely going
into this I think we have very different
energetic frequencies I have I think we
have different roles I think we have
different goals I have I think we have
different things that make us happy for
example men run towards risk women
prefer safety and stability you know
it's and and that you know is replicated
in our biology we have testosterone we
have faster reflexes denser muscles more
muscle mass we are designed for risk for
danger if you are around a woman all the
time it's a good thing when you need to
heal to rest women can remind you to
enjoy life it's a beautiful thing to
have loyal support from a woman I mean
if you're sick and and so on if you're
stressed there's nothing better your
brother can't give you that feminine
care it's a very magical very valuable
thing and that's why we see the prophet
saying take care of your women such an
important thing take care of your women
because it's a beautiful thing to have
that partnership so yes we are designed
to coexist with women to be compliment
complimentary with each other but I
think where a lot of men go wrong is
they think it's normal to be around
their women 365 days a year that will
bring down your energies that will
change you as a man it will lead you to
being a bit resentful I'll give you an
example like the vast majority of guys I
know in the west they don't have any
hobes anymore all they do is sit and
watch other men play sport on on TV or
they play video games watching some
fictional character do cool things what
happened to men doing cool things so I
firmly believe in the the the power of
men coming together and doing manly
things whether that's going to a boxing
gym whether that's going to a BJJ gym
whether it's going to the mused
regularly but I think I really do
believe in men going out and doing
adventures together again we talked
about this last time you go on a
motorbiking trip somewhere go go going
you know go on a a shooting trip or
you're working on your your weapons and
tactics skills go on a whether a surfing
trip or a kickboxing camp in tand for a
week go and do adventurous masculine
things with your brothers at least one
week a year and get a feeling of hey my
energy is different I feel more
disciplined I have more of an edge I
feel my testosterone's higher that's
called the masculine frame now the Tes
Liv in that all the time I live in that
all the time I make sure the majority of
time I spend is with my brothers
focusing on Mission focusing on health
doing traditionally masculine things I
think that's the natural state for man
to live in and if you around woman all
the time she could be the best woman in
the world she could be super supportive
and amazing but it's still it's going to
change you and calm you down in a way
that maybe isn't natural maybe we're
meant to be out there with the brothers
hunting fighting you know bringing back
the bread so to speak or you know the
meat so I I really think men spend way
too much time focused on women and
focused on sex do we really need sex
that much really it's not oxygen Lads
everyone's got this the physical thirst
all right sure that that builds over
time I get that but the main problem is
mental thirst
and a lot of the western Society tries
to put that in you with the songs and
the videos and oh baby I'll be happy if
only you give me some validation what
R&B it's a mess man it's a mess now look
whether that's trauma based because
someone didn't get any love from their
mom and they're trying to get that from
women or whether that's some sort of hey
if I have a pretty chick on my arm then
then all the lads will think that I'm
special it just it's nonsense men need
to drop that mental thirst and drop the
the overwhelming focus on women and sex
and validation from women and focus on
more meaningful things we we again it's
not it's not oxygen we don't need it all
the time this it's not even like this
ho-ha energy thing that he's talking
about cuz the American journals of
Endocrinology they found that there's
this thing called menstrual
synchronization where it's like when
women spend too much time with each
other their menstrual cycles actually
sink right where their hormonal Cycles
actually sink and you're telling me as a
man with testosterone it's not going to
have an impact on you come on as I mean
social Neuroscience talks about the the
energetic or the emotional economy and
you know you go on to the subway in
London everyone's depressed you're going
to feel a bit you go into a fight gy and
everyone's you're going to feel a bit oh
you know what I mean and if you were
around your brothers who are all ideally
on the dean and and have their life in
order and disciplin and keeping their
Fitness right that's the optimal state
for a man to live not doing a boring job
going home and sitting and watching TV
at the end of the day with who who might
be an amazing wife again not speaking
against the supportive wives out there
but men need to be with other men doing
adventurous traditionally masculine
things to be in that optimal masculine
frame where they are able to bring about
the highest output and therefore the
best benefits for their family for
Society for for you know the most
positive life they can live you know I
actually have direct experience with
this that I love the women in my life
you know I love my mom I love my grandma
my sister my nieces my
wife but there was a time in my life
where I lived in this lake house with
just brothers I was a Muslim at the time
so I shouldn't just call him Brothers I
just friends right okay oh man now
before this I was working out two three
times a week and my nutrition you know
yada yada y once I moved into the lake
house nothing changed nutrition the same
workouts the
same but my body composition and my
strength skyrocketed to levels that I I
I couldn't even explain a chemical thing
brother isn't it like it's deep it's
real it really is being around men who
are all focused all hustling together
that is such a powerful hack to the
young men out there who really want to
get themselves ahead in life find some
other men who are hungry to train right
to build businesses to get the money
right and spend time with men hustling
and growing not just chasing headism and
chasing women all the time I'm so sick
of how many men especially in the west
Focus so much energy on on on what on
sex what for pleasure you know they're
not trying to make babies so what are
they doing they're chasing pleasure what
are you what do you a child who wants to
eat chocolate all the time like what's
wrong with these people men need to
address their mental thirst and focus
that Sexual Energy which I mean if you
want to read up on on on Freud I mean a
lot of his stuff was weird right but one
of the things he said was nothing good
in life comes from you know that that
other than which you see a man using his
Sexual Energy Applied to nonsexual
things you know I'm not a big reader of
Freud I might have butchered that I I
preferred yung's approach on on things
but back when I used to think that stuff
had Merit then I found something called
the Quran but um the idea that that
Sexual Energy is is a very deep and very
powerful thing if you waste it all just
chasing women you are losing so much
potential in life whereas if you get all
that distraction away and you focus on
on the dean you be around other men you
focus on your training using that energy
for things other than chasing Hedonism
and sex wow it amplifies you like when
you're around those Brothers how much
harder were you training how much more
focused hours did you have each day to
to build business businesses to work on
projects it's a different way of living
man I mean personally like I said from
that
example in that time of my life I hate
to say that I was not very motivated I
wasn't really doing much and the only
times that we were spending it was doing
degenerate things see that's what I mean
you were using that Sexual Energy or
that that Primal Life Force to conquer
it's not really a lot of the time it's
not even about sex it's just this
Conquest energy to build and Conquer
they say that the drive of testosterone
is to to fornicate and to fight and to
conquer to build right you can use that
for degeneracy or you can use that to
build an Empire yeah but man if you
around women all the time you're not
going to get up at 5:00 a.m. and go you
know fudger and go for a jog this
beautiful nice warm woman next like it's
I I question how much time as men we are
meant to really spend around women I
think the natural state is to be with
other men out adventuring coming back to
your woman to rest to recover but then
to get back out there doing
traditionally masculine things with men
it's because a woman is soft by nature
woman is feminine and that's very very
useful especially as a man if we've been
with a lot of men we become you know uh
it's going to sound a little suspicious
but we become harder yeah and in the
process of becoming more harder we need
that softness to like bring us back down
to normal level but too much of it too
much of it makes us weak and then you
get resentful and then you'll lose
passion in the relationship and it's
yeah I I think that I think the nuclear
family model doesn't work a woman a man
kids everyone has different energetic
frequencies why are we all around each
other all the time I think the natural
state is it does take a village to raise
a child I've wrote up on this like 150
people in a tribe the kids go and play
with their kids the women are with the
women the men are with the men I think
that's the most natural way I really do
and so I think this nuclear family is a
is a modern artificial construct that
doesn't really serve anyone to you know
in in a in a positive manner do people
really think the prophet the man so the
greatest of creation who conquered so
much LED so many battles bro you really
think he had time to just be home 24/7
sit and watch Netflix complaining to his
wife yeah for
real yeah it's true he was living in the
masculine frame and that and he had his
he had his tribe he had the sahaba you
know he had his he had his boys it's
amazing people should read up on on the
fun they had together and the adventures
they had honestly and I think the modern
day representation of that I really
enjoy motorcycle trips with the brothers
I love it it's like the the modern day
equivalent of riding with your horses
with your boys across the you know
across the fields get getting out on
motorbikes you know in in interesting
countries is a fantastic way to
replicate that ancient Lads going on
adventures together strongly recommended
really you do that here in UAE uh yeah
I've done it here I I've done it um all
over basically all over how do you view
driver now here that's all right you
just got to man you got you got to stay
sharp situational awareness is key it'll
keep you alive and and actions on
continency planning every time you
approach a junction what is the
incredible worst case scenario and how
do you plan for it so that if you do see
an indication of it coming you can act
right away yeah so these people are here
crazy yeah the roads the roads can be
challenged definitely um and and again I
I recommend motorcycling but at the same
time I
[Music]
don't I I think um yeah get get put some
money into training and really have your
head on a swivel and ride with other
guys who are safe it's it's a beautiful
thing there's something speaking about
relationships and marriage and being at
home 24/7 unfortunately a lot of men do
that we were talking about this off
camera you you had this I don't want to
say change of heart but this new found
refined perspective on relationships you
talked about there's a difference
between going for practical First and
romantic second what do you mean by this
definitely so I think the Western model
of of choosing a long-term relationship
based on emotions is deeply flawed
because emotions come and go and a
relationship is a practical thing you
know all the emotions in the world won't
help you if you have entirely different
priorities in life and expectations in
life so I really do think that if you
want a relationship to be lasting there
should be a practical conversation what
are your goals in life what are my goals
in life do they match what are your
expectations do you think it's sexist if
I expect you to cook a meal for me if
I'm working 12-hour days you got to have
this chat first cuz if the Practical
doesn't add up the emotions they're
going to fade relationships are
practical things especially when kids
come in you can have all the sex and
passion and all she's so pretty you want
that's not going to help help you when
you're running a household with numerous
screaming kids and bills to be paid
there needs to be that practical
alignment so I think a practical
conversation between man and woman
before they engage in a relationship
before they even take their clothes off
is absolutely essential and it's not in
any way represented as a healthy thing
in the West in the west oh she's pretty
oh try and try and capture her or oh you
know he's he's exciting and he makes you
feel butteries oh that's a good choice
no emotions fade relationships must be
based on practical complimentarity you
must fit together both now and long term
you know there's a che code to this
right tell me in Islam there's this
Hadith where the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he says that
when you usually marry you marry for
looks uh status wealth and Dean wealth
and Dean and he says if you're going to
choose choose the dean is that amazing
that's that's said man the more I learn
the more I'm like yes see it's true if
you choose somebody on the dean you're
going to have a life that matches you're
going to have expectations that match
you're going to have respect between two
parties it's going to be based on
practical not emotional so this is
something I discovered as a as a you
know late 30s It Was Written hundreds of
years ago there's so much knowledge in
the Quran if only I'd found it earlier I
I I one of my regrets is that I didn't
find Islam earlier I mean alhamdulillah
that I found it but man I've learned so
much through trial and error and and
some some difficult situations that is
already written in something hundreds
and hundreds of years ago if only I just
found this Dean earlier I could have
avoided so much hassle I feel that but
umy I'm the love for finding it later
than
Ed this whole thing you're talking about
about the marriage is the n itself not a
contract technically 100% practical
between two parties if there's no you're
not you're not drunk impregnating oh no
we need to get married you are two
level-headed people sitting down with
suppor of your family discussing does
this make sense on a practical level it
it it's beautiful Allah says in the
Quran that we've put passionate love and
mercy between spouses right as Rami
usually you know references it's a
beautiful Ayah in the Quran and this is
important because it's to understand
that this is not some R pill PE you know
black and white relationship between man
and woman we have love we have trust we
have romance but this comes after the
ncah many of the Great sh contemporary
Scholars they've mentioned Never Fall in
Love Before ncah never you know enter
the woman have intimacy do Z or har with
the woman before nah isn't that exactly
what I just discussed that took me 40
years to discover it's remarkable it's
remarkable it's and it's it's so
beautiful I remember when I was working
in Iran in
2007 a friend of mine had an organized
marriage and we're talking about it I
said isn't that kind of weird don't you
get to choose he said well you kind of
get to choose cuz my parents have put
forward numerous options and you know
you have a chat and see what's going to
work like but what about passion he's
like no the passion will come I remember
in my head thinking man that's crazy
that's just silly you can't you got to
try before you buy all this sort of
thinking but guess what that sort of
relationship will work cuz it's based on
mutual respect it's based on practical
complimentarity two people sitting down
on a logical level saying do our lives
match do our priorities match do our
expectations match great and then from
that place of practical Foundation they
discover each other they discover
passion and it works it lasts much
better than this oh he's so sexy he's
got to flies 2 years later they're
divorced a lot of these brothers on that
are watching the podcast they they
support Andrew T you know a lot of them
are not Muslims so they might look at
marriage as something like so grandiose
right SOI do you want to quickly just
break down what an Islamic marriage is
and how it's not really a big deal like
the actual process of getting married
it's not like in the west you know some
big $500,000 ring all you need all you
need to get married the man the woman
the father of the woman to to give her
hand to you in marriage um the you know
proposal acceptance a gift for the woman
could be anything she wants and
something the guy you know agrees on
giving her noce and then two male
Witnesses that's it you don't need a big
flashy party you don't need uh music
actually music is Haram so you can't be
doing that you don't need to throw rast
pedals you can if you want but Allah
makes it easy and you know what let's
take it back 1400 years ago to the time
of the Prophet or any normal society
that that values Chasity for men and
women committing Zen is
hard you have to get out and go to their
house and not be seen or they have to
come to your house not be seen it's like
there's no like Hotel you can go like
it's Zen is hard nikah was easy
marriage is easy nowaday it's flipped
marriage is difficult people make it
difficult the government makes it
insanely difficult I can understand in
the west why you wouldn't want to get
married it's terrifying yeah yeah cuz as
a man um you know you get married you
get divorced and then you lose half
yourself there's that risk um as a woman
I mean yeah even as a woman some women
they fear um kind of you know basically
they get cheated on they get divorced
and they don't you know they can't
offend for themselves they didn't go to
school or whatever they relied on their
husband now they're alone and child
support the guy's paying $200 a month
it's not enough to get by and she's a
single all this all this stuff so both
ends is like there's no protection for
either that's why Islam is perfect cuz
you know has a system for this but it's
because and back to the last topic
people look at their spouse as a product
rather than an investment right when you
you said like uh you got to test it
before you buy it that's for a product
it's for a car that's for you know golf
clubs even you got to test it yeah um
what's an investment an investment is
something you look into does it make
sense is it you know compatible with you
know how much I have how much I can
spend where I'm you looking to be in the
future is a projection uh there does it
make sense your spouse is an
investment and they're investing in you
just as much as you're investing in them
it's a genuine partnership I find if the
nikar process and you know marriages
that are based on practical you know
talked about discussions for me it feels
a lot more like a partnership whereas in
the west a lot of the time a marriage is
a competition
both parties are trying to out earn each
other or be the boss or it's just just a
mess it's it's there's no polarity
there's no complimentarity it's
literally everyone's trying to be as
masculine as they can and everyone's
kind of irritating each other and it
just doesn't work so to the to the men
in the west especially a Muslim Brothers
in the west who are looking to get
married yeah find find someone who takes
their faith seriously and has the same
expectations as you and ideally get out
of the West I mean I I I can't see how
as a masculine man who likes traditional
values and wants to get married and have
a big family I can't see how being in
the west serves you I really can't I I
don't see again if especially if you if
you're on your dean and you're you you
adhere strongly to Traditional Values
and you reject liberalism and you reject
all this wokeism and stuff you got to
see the trend of these Western countries
it's not heading in your
direction I think the only move is to
get you and your family out of all that
disgusting programming as soon as
possible man my son is 10 he's in Sweden
in his classroom there are 25 children
10 year olds three of them identify as
trans that's a little higher than the
national average right like it's in
fifth grade yeah and he's he's read
books and he's asked me dad like I've
had to read books that have words like
homosexuality transexual bisexuality
this is in the school curriculum of a
10-year-old he's not allowed to miss
gender in his classroom or the teacher
gets angry at him bro look into it
deeply Sweden has gender neutral
preschools and again somewhere like
Sweden or comia sorry California these
places are you know especially
California they're at the Forefront of
the culture that you see spreading
around the world get away from it it's
only going to get worse it's only going
to get worse for anyone with Traditional
Values or living on the dean or who
rejects all this wocus liberal Satanist
rub
the W take your familywhere else I think
it's the only the only move on the at
this point so how do we reclaim the
narrative with this leftist agenda leave
and let Let Them Burn themselves to the
ground man like and I mean that entirely
symbolically I'm not in any way s I'm
not suggesting any harm I'm saying these
people are Their Own Worst Enemy and
their belief systems make them unhappy
again the ultimate question for any
liberalist wocus how are your belief
systems working out for you are you you
fulfilled are you healthy do you have
supportive loving family members around
you are you winning at life they don't
tend to be very happy so let leave them
to play their strange games and move to
a place where ideally it's funny I used
to think that religion and state should
be separated but if religion and state
are separated then you have politicians
running it and they're not checked by
any sort of high power they're going to
do what politicians are going to do
they're going to be corrupt everything
is going to get strange come to a
country where there is that balance of
religion and State where the leaders are
God-fearing where the law is based on
religion on Sharia and you will not have
to worry about your children being
pushed to be transsexual you will not
have a classroom where three out of the
25 kids as per my son's classroom in
Sweden identifies as transexual as
10-year-olds it's perverted it's
disgusting it is damaging for young
minds get your families out of those
environments and bring them to somewhere
where basic healthy morality is kept in
place firmly by a system of law that
aligns with religion I mean you remind
me of this one Ayah in in the Quran when
Allah is talking to uh Lam Prophet lot
and it's after you know all these people
are out here trying to do heinous crimes
you know men against men and Lam's
instructed in the morning you know just
leave and it says leave your family
leave your wife right cuz she was a
sympathizer with the lgtv electronics
movement and Allah is saying just leave
don't look back and just leave I think
he took his family and his wife but his
wife turned around because she couldn't
she turned she turned around because she
loved the people more than Allah and her
family and she was taken with the the
destruction as well yeah
but the reason I I think you should also
look at as you mentioned the trajectory
right they have increasing mental uh
health issues and the rate of which
people anti depressant usage all these
things people are massively depressed
they're not happy so the whole question
of how are how is it working out for you
clearly not very well also look at the
trajectory 20 years ago we didn't have
this kind of propaganda this kind of
stuff in schools what happened was in
Europe since they were dominated by the
church and it was oppressive they
flipped it they said we want to be
secular we want to make our own rules
this paved the way for now God's out of
the equation he doesn't get to dictate
anything now they're trying to remove
parents from the equation because they
were the last stronghold for Traditional
Values and once they're out of the
equation they the government will own
everyone complete communist control yeah
man the Cold War never ended it just
flipped sides you know wow I know people
who are moving to Russia to escape
communism who would have
thought it's remarkable it really is
strange times we live in but yeah I
think alhamdulillah for UAE genuinely I
mean that like I plan to retire here I I
think this is the best country in the
world by far I think the leadership here
look at what they've done in a a
traditionally very volatile region how
many different nationalities are living
in in UAE with full religious freedom
with with safety safety is important
Europe's starting to realize that it's
pretty important with
full like protection of children's Minds
there are no sexual agendas being pushed
on kids in in the schools here
alhamdulillah for this country and
alhamdulillah for the leaders for having
created such a safe
grounded
holistically Halal place in terms of
raising a family it's safe to raise your
kids here without all this weird
programming alhamdulillah for that it's
very rare in today's day and age and I
think the word's out I think the world
has realized Dubai is the place to raise
a family Dubai is the place to be if
obviously don't speak against a religion
don't act in any way stupid on the
streets then everyone's safe you know
don't do anything you shouldn't do
anyway and you will live a good life
here in the UAE alhamdulillah for this
country I fiercely believe in it more
and more with the more I I learn about
how this country was built and how the
leaders brought this this Prett pretty
much I'd see it as a Utopia into
existence Subhan Allah it it really is
because they allow that freedom for the
people that are coming in just to the
day we were at this coffee shop this
brother from actually I can't say
brother cuz he's not Muslim but he he's
from Uganda okay and when we were
talking with him turns out he's
Christian and he was he said he goes to
the church all the time I'm like they
got churches in UAE he's like yeah they
have a church I'm like wow Subhan Allah
100% I can see no better societal model
globally in the UAE and I've been around
I'm approaching 100 countries I've lived
in over a dozen and when I travel I'm
not doing the tourist thing I'm
interacting with significant people and
understanding the country I see no
better societal model than the UAE I see
no better run built and run country than
the UAE this is the place Lads get over
here
Ser love to please let me know if I can
assist I'd love to make it easy thank
you thank you appreciate it brother I
wanted to say this before I forget
please please please but do you know how
to do morning Adar and evening Adar have
you heard of this I I is that additional
sunna
prayer so these are uh it's part of it
is you're reciting the three I think the
three final suras or just three suras in
the end yeah the three final so you have
Surah Surah Al and Surah Al I know
surlas um but I wasn't familiar with
saying those three yeah and then another
one is reciting a now I know brother
you're new more new than most uh Muslim
and all three of us here and I don't
know all of it myself but if you if you
repeat these or at least if you just put
it on and listen to it in the morning
and in the evening what it does is it
actually protects you from evil eye oh
lovely and for you since you are just
starting to you know be on the online
space since you've been behind the
scenes most of the
time I really do suggest just that you
start doing that it will protect you in
will protect you I love that thank you
see isn't that interesting I've been
what I reverted in January so we're
going on what 8 nine months I've been
putting in effort to learn I'm still
learning and yet we're going to somehow
criticize Tate who doesn't have any
Muslim Brothers around him doesn't have
any support there is so much to learn as
a revert it's you you change your
perspective on life you change your
daily routines you drop certain things
you adopt new habits there is so much
change involved in getting on the de
even though I'm in the Middle East and I
have support so much support from so
many incredible Brothers I'm still
learning things myself significantly
every day like it's there's so much to
learn and and inshallah the Tes inshah
Tristan takes your I'm not sure I
wouldn't bet on that though but uh we
can try but inshah Andrew gets over here
they both get over here and they can get
on the dean properly with the support
that that they deserve that every every
revert deserves you know I think it's a
real privilege to have to be so
supported uh I've been benefited from
that they haven't so I'd love to see
them over here we'd love to send you
these bro but just to go into that so
there's aith where you know he reported
that the prophet said he who recites
three times every morning and evening
I'll give you this English translation R
it says in the name of Allah with whose
name there is protection against every
kind of harm in the Earth or in the
heaven and he is the all hearing and the
all knowing nothing will harm him so if
you mention this three times just in the
morning and the evening you're good and
then there's another one basically it's
this other ofar that you do it says oh
Allah you are my rob you are my Lord
there is no true God except you you have
created me and I'm your slave and I hold
to your Covenant as far as I can I seek
refuge in you from the evil of what I
have done I acknowledge the favors that
you have bestowed upon me and I confess
my sins pardon me for none but you has
the power to Pardon so if a man or woman
recites this in the morning and he
doesn't make it to the night guaranteed
jna and if you mentioned this at night
let's say before you go to sleep after M
or is and you don't make it to the
morning guaranteed J and there's also
ones that you can do like for traveling
Prophet used to mention traveling yeah
so in we'll give these to you I used to
do da sa when I wasn't even Muslim yeah
like 10 years ago yeah 10 years ago just
cuz I liked it and I learned it in
Arabic and I used to say it like I
thought I thought it was a good thing
like it's I love the Arabic language
it's it's a complicated thing but I
absolutely love it so so speaking about
that do you know how to recite Surah fa
F I do yeah you're going to you're going
to test me live right now
okay
alhamd boom was
nice
nice but the thing is when you really
look into even the even the meaning of
Surah fat just just the first Surah it's
mindbending and you can spend a lot of
time just you know looking into that for
example the root coming from the word
womb so in in in Allah subhah waala
cares for you and loves you the way a
mother cares for her baby in the womb
it's beautiful there's so much depth
even in the first Surah and there
there's a whole book full of it it's
it's incredible so for me it's it's such
an energizing thing the more I learn the
more I'm hungry to learn more to the
point where I am saying no to money I'm
scaling back certain businesses because
genuinely the time I put into learning
about Islam is so much more fulfilling
and so much more energizing and just
more real like it's alhamdulillah for
the depth in Islam it's mindbending yeah
you know that's a blessing right because
it's it's known that when Allah loves an
individual He blesses them with the
knowledge of Islam like with learning
more I do feel blessed I feel incredibly
fortunate to have found Islam genuinely
the the overwhelming predominant emotion
I have when praying is just gratitude
it's it's intense deep gratitude and
that's where some of the emotions come
in such a beautiful thing very beautiful
Allah says in the Quran if you're if
you're grateful indeed I'll increase you
I'll give you more I feel that I feel
that and I've noticed too Salah again I
don't want to keeping anything or say
anything inappropriate it's a little bit
like if I'm allowed to say it like going
to the gym once you're going to the gym
regularly you need to keep going yeah
same thing with praying regularly
getting going is a bit challenging but
once you're going you'll miss it so much
it's a momentum thing it really is it's
healthy habits once you've got them
going they're easy it's beautiful that
you said that you
are uh starting to take away time from
the business stuff and you're putting it
more towards Allah and learning about
Islam when you do this you're
essentially giving up the for the and
when you do this that thing that you're
giving up maybe some part of your mind
is thinking I'm going to take a little L
here I'm going to lose some money or
some time in the business or some
Outreach or whatever but you're going to
gain so much more not just not just in
the a not just in like afterlife but
what you gave up Allah will give you
even more of isn't that interesting I
see it like a double win if you give up
you know Hedonism or you know being
obsessed with money or all these things
you're already winning in the da and you
win in the as well I can see it's a
double win it really is sub Subhan so um
I want to start off by something that IM
he said he said that patience and
gratitude are like the same thing right
he said that patience is gratitude in
tough times and gratitude is is is
patience during Good Times
and something I'm curious about is you
know when you have your customade
reality you have everything you could
really want in this dun is there a part
of you that just says you know doesn't
might not get much better than this I'll
just wait for
agenda very interesting question brother
um I'm I'm not asking for it to get
better again I don't pray for myself in
any way but man it's getting better
every year it's it's just happening you
know there's there's more businesses
there's more starting projects there's
more incredible adventures with my Lads
there's more insights about Islam
there's more seeing you know my family
my kids get stronger my my brothers wi
it's just this massive ongoing positive
momentum and I'm sure there'll be
obstacles I'm sure there'll be
challenges but life is so good and just
keeps every I used to say this with the
Tates every year is the best year yet
and and and I I put it to the tapate
brothers even though they're going
through what they're going through
they're still learning they're still
having a positive impact on on the world
more than they were able to last year so
this is their best year year as well
like I think that that mindset of every
year is the best year yet and even if it
isn't alhamdulillah Allah like I think
the answer to that question without
being in any way rude is I don't care
like maybe maybe not genuinely whatever
happens I'm extremely blessed and I'm
extremely grateful and it could all be
terrible it could all be amazing either
way alhamdulillah like it's I don't even
think about it to be honest which is
interesting cuz for the the longest of
time my main focus in life was how do I
make my life situation better I used to
write lists about what I wanted to
change I used to have plans and
strategies and pushing now I'm just like
life is great keeps getting better
alhamdulillah and if it doesn't
alhamdulillah it's it's I'm in a state
now where I'm free from concern about my
life situation whatever happens happens
you know having said that I'm incredibly
blessed so it's easy to be in that state
right I wasn't in that state for the
longest of time I was very stressed
about my life and angry about it and
wanting to change it wow alhamdulillah I
think that's a beautiful answer I think
it's very CU it capsules the Hadith that
you mentioned before that um amazing is
the affair of a Believer when he's
tested something difficult happens you
know he's patient and that's better for
him and when something good happens
alhamdulillah and that's better for him
and I think the patien thing is
difficult if you're a young man who
wants to build that Empire get the money
right have you know positive
relationships win with the boys you want
it now right yeah and I see a I see a
lot of that I see a lot of guys on
social media in their teens or you know
early 20s living this big flash life I
didn't live flash I started working when
I was what 12 I was gamefully employed
since then I didn't really start living
flash till I met the Tates even in my
late 30s when I was a middle 30s I was a
millionaire you'd never know I was
living very sensible through seeing the
Tates and thinking hang on maybe
actually want to enjoy life and see if I
can Inspire others to see what's
possible as well I started Living Large
but what I mean some might not agree
with that but I I think to the young men
out there who want to improve their life
situation yes get angry yes know that
you can can create better yes go and
create that better have that sense of
urgency where you want to get the most
out of every day but also on the flip
side understand it can take decades to
change your life 85% of people are born
and die in the same wealth bracket in
developed countries 85% it's very rare
to find those outliers who were born at
the bottom and made their way to the top
it takes decades to get that I mean I'm
an example of that Tates are an extreme
example of that they came from the
ghetto to Flying private owning Bugattis
and and you know being being hyper
wealthy
find those people and and you know learn
their traits learn their patterns learn
what you can from people who've gone
from the bottom to the top but
understand you don't see on social media
the fact that it take can take decades
you don't see the the hours and hours of
endless focused effort so yeah in the
world where everyone wants that success
now yes get angry yes deserve it yes
apply yourself but understand you could
have to be angry and disciplined for
decades before you really get to where
you feel ah I'm not poor anymore
everything's good yeah and that's very
real because you'll have a lot of
YouTubers who are like you want to get
rich fast just follow buy my course 85
bucks and pay my pay my bills and then
I'll show you some wi exactly and
there's no there's no quick win and
that's what I like about that Tates
product the real world they say this is
not a get-rich quick thing you need to
put in the effort they say if you're not
putting in the effort it ain't going to
work for you there is no magic pill you
know and they put a lot of effort in
their coaching and all the mentoring
inside to keep people motivated keep
them healthy keep them fit keep them
disciplined it needs to be a whole Body
Mind Body ideally Faith aligned on on
everyday striving for success for many
many years before you get that success
and if you don't if you get it quick if
you get that crypto pump your life's
going to suck anyway if you go and build
an Empire without struggling who are you
as a man what are your stories what what
are your obstacles overcome what have
you really achieved so I I think people
should embrace the fact that it takes
years they should embrace the struggle
wanting that quick money eh it's not
even real I I wouldn't pursue that as is
real it takes decades to build your
Empire Embrace that struggle yeah I
agree with that because I'm very early
on as are all of us you accept yourself
and calling me old bro huh what no
you're
success I'm playing I'm playing I got
gray hair that's why I shave it it's
okay no but it it's befitting it looks
very nice on
you but in terms of like our success and
all that we're very young in the game
and man you made me lose my TR thought
bro oh good man you guys are doing well
I'll pick it up for you like you guys
are look okay some people will have more
Ferraris than
you you can inherit money Daddy can buy
you a Ferrari who cares you guys are
having a positive impact on Humanity
what you're doing has gone out to
millions of people and no doubt had
positive impacts on many of them that's
a form of wealth you may not be able to
count it in a bank account butul that's
that's real man I would take that over
Ferraris and I have Ferraris so it's
like I'm telling you what you're doing
is more meaningful alhamdulillah so I
remember alhamdulillah so what I was
saying is
that since we're so young in it we're
essentially like little babies and we
haven't gone through that like passage
of Rights and that passage of Rights is
going through all those struggles
throughout the years to have the point
where you have youve made it you have
this wealth the made man status exactly
been through it so you know what it's
like and you can speak about it but if
you have a guy and he just out of
nowhere gets a crypto pump well he
didn't go through the passage of right a
nerd who's got some cash mate exactly
what what you are now is you're
essentially just uh you're just a boy
who has money you're not a man yet and
again you can inherit money you can be
given money through no achievement
whatsoever I think I think money is
valued as a metric because you can count
it you can see it you know it's palpable
but
it doesn't equate to value value is
value in a man what struggles have you
been through what stories what
capabilities do you have what brothers
do you have around you and what caliber
are those brothers and how much do they
respect you that's value you know what
what what benefits and value and support
and capability can you bring to your
fellow brother whether it's in business
or in you know if it's a violent
situation you got to protect each other
all these sorts of things that's value
man a man you can trust who you can rely
on who you know could I call it the the
the African jail test
you know I I'm I'm falsely accused I'm
in jail I need x amount of money to bail
me out how many men can you say without
questioning would get that 10 grand and
get on that that that plane and be there
and navigate and do whatever they need
to do and get you out it's these sorts
of things are value men you can rely on
with capability is value you can't you
can't inherit that you got to build it
you know what I mean I think everyone's
chasing the wrong form of value if you
were a man who was on The Dean and you
were truly living a good respectable
life you have more value than the vast
majority of ultra highet worth
individuals out there I'd rather talk to
you than you know Mr average I'm worth
100 million I'm so special nine times
out of 10 they're just money nerds
anyway who've neglected all the other
areas of their life I think it's really
important to yes get your money right
but don't view it as the be all and end
all metric of of what what is value as a
man it's just one form of wealth and
there are many more meaningful forms of
wealth and more fulfilling forms of
wealth out there so how would a man
start to gain more of value in this
sense I think you need to seek out
struggle Tate speaks to this really well
I mean if you're a young man who's broke
get yourself in a fight gy and and you
know I took the military path I mean I
can't really recommend that cuz most
wars nowadays are just you know falsely
generated for the military-industrial
complex this is this is basic stuff but
seek out struggle with other men and
fight clubs are a great way to do it I
started my son boxing when he was three
I started my daughter boxing when she
was two I have a video of me holding her
hand while she's throwing knees when she
was 2 years old you know what I mean
like it's I I I think being exposed to
struggle and risk is what builds value
and being around other men who are also
pushing to improve themselves in such a
fashion Subhan Allah so how do you
assess the value of another man It's
Tricky mate one thing I screen for is is
red flags um now obviously for me I'm
going to be more prone to trust and view
a man as as high value man if he's on
the dean obviously cuz then his value
system is is checked out you know it's
real um is he is he physically capable
does he keep himself fit that speaks to
discipline but in terms of red flags man
one of the best ways to assess whether a
man is of value in my mind is is he
thirsty is he thirsty for women female
validation is he thirsty for cash these
are the sorts of men who I view as low
value and you can have ultra high net
worth individuals men worth 30 million
and up but they will they will shark you
for a deal or they will they will throw
your friendship under the bus because oh
there's a chance with a girl who came
with you all this sort of stuff like to
to me real value as a man is capability
which is born over time through facing
struggle risk and so on it it's being on
the dean or or you know living true to
those values that of that of holding
yourself to account that of being aware
that you know Shayan does exist and
Temptation does exist and you need to
say no to these things and it's a man
you can rely on a man you can rely on to
to do what needs to be done in your time
of need that that's a number one metric
is it a capable man who you can rely on
who have his has his life together and
can support you in your time of need now
ideally you're not in a time of need
where you don't need him to you know run
into a situation of violence to help you
but that's what I look for in a man
capable discreet loyal reliable who's
got his life in order and ideally
nowadays is is very much on the dean
that's a high value man do you have a
certain way of testing to be able to
filter the men that come into your life
out or to bring them in I mean look it's
changed now since reverting right
previously I would watch how they act
around women I I need to see how they
interacted with their woman like the how
the way a man interacts with a woman is
a very good example of how much he's got
his life in order whether he can hold
frame whether he is an actual leader or
I mean you don't want to go into
business with a man who gets bossed
around by a lady or is thirsty for
female validation cuz he'll throw you
under the bus for that female validation
right so that was always a good way to
and and and
um you know other successful guys I know
also said you can you learn a lot about
a man from the dynamic he has with his
with his woman um but nowadays I don't
really hang out with men and their women
you know so I can't assess in that
manner um I think over time first of all
is he on is he on his Dean properly does
he take his faith seriously that's a f
that's probably the number one filter
nowadays because again if someone truly
believes they will answer for everything
that they do they're going to be a good
person right they're held to account um
but over yeah just just trust very
slowly I I to be honest I don't know
whether this is halal or not but I I
view
everybody very negatively initially I I
assume the worst out of people until
they've proven me otherwise now again I
don't know whether that's in alignment
with their faith maybe it's something I
need to change but I assume that people
are lazy I assume that people want the
most benefit for the least effort I
assume that most people are
undisciplined I assume that most people
are not even conscious of their actions
or you know they lack self-awareness
like I need to see all these qualities
as as being not true in someone before I
fully trust them and fully view them as
high value so I just say it takes time
man and again if someone's on their day
and great they can level up in terms of
my perspective of them pretty quickly
but you have to be slow to trust in
today's day and age you have to be
everyone can put on a good face everyone
can pretend to be you know a guy with
his his life in order but you need to
see them under under some sort of
pressure I mean ideally you know get in
the ring with someone that's a good
flavor of someone's character or get on
the Range and do some good training with
them there um do do business with them
be involved in someone when money is
involved that's a good way to see
someone's character you know whether
they're thirsty for that cash or they
value their honor and your friendship
above any amount of money I have friends
who I know would say no to a billion
dollars if it meant losing their honor
you know Honorable Men Who money doesn't
matter next to next to my faith and next
to the standards I hold myself to
account but it takes time to see these
things so yeah I'm not sure if I'm
answering your question very effectively
but takes time man you just got to
assess with time see them in in
situations of risk see them in
situations with money um understand
their Dynamic with women are they
thirsty or not that's that's what I'd be
looking for in Islam there's uh I think
it's a Hadith I'm not quite sure but the
way that you can really know someone is
if you've traveled with them lived with
them and done business with them un like
it there it is you know and it's written
100 years ago yeah Subhan Allah and I
remember I won't say any names I don't I
don't want to expose anyone but I had
stayed at this brother's house and when
it was time for fer he would not wake up
for fer okay and I would try like I
would try to wake him up I would say and
he was conscious of it he would wake up
and then he would go right back to sleep
MH and to me like when I saw that I was
like huh like it ringed an alarm like
something off here yep and you got to
listen to those red flags yeah since
with men and women when you see a red
flag in someone believe it when someone
shows you who they really are believe it
and take action I I'll do that I'll cut
people out I don't mean to cut you off
I'll cut people out of my life all the
time people know that I'm that guy who
says sorry I can't accept that in my
life until you change it we're not
communicating no be that guy you need to
sorry to cut your off yeah no I I just
think it's so important that we learn
to be able to test and filter people out
because now not everyone that comes into
our life is meant to be in our lives
right and we're speaking with the
brother Ahmed and he has like the the LV
bag MH the the blue LV bag he's got 500k
cash and this that's actually an amazing
filter if you think about it because how
many people uh when you put 500k on the
table they're going to look at you and
their true colors are going to come out
interesting dollars or durhams dollars I
think dollars yeah cuz he travels with
it if I remember correctly you have to
declare that at Customs that's tricky I
talk to him about that yeah yeah I don't
he's doing well there's no doubt about
that yeah interesting but think about it
like if someone hasn't
seen that much money in their life and
you just throw 500k on the table and
you're kind of like showing them like
okay this money we can do whatever with
it
mhm I don't know where I heard this from
oh actually I heard Andrew T say it
first and then I heard ahed say it as
well but they said that money is a
amplifier yeah I agree with that
definitely definitely definitely I think
people have issues around certain things
money sex death and and and that's why I
think it's good to be with men who you
are considering To Be Your Inner Circle
in situations involve risk you had a
good you know and and with the business
do business with them because you
involve money these are all areas you
can see is someone in control of their
issues or if their issues in control of
them awesome Subhan Allah travels with
500k that's that's pretty gangster it's
crazy right nice so it's not the money
itself that makes you greedy but if you
already had greed inside you the money
just amplifies that yeah and I find the
the inverse to be very very real as well
like if you you're very generous before
money you just don't have the means to
give when you do have the means to give
inshah you're very even more generous
and what and then what that comes down
to I figured this out from Human
Experience but then I realized it was
written hundreds of years ago it's about
your intent it's about neara the intent
you have in your heart with which you
approach business with which you
approach relationships if you're coming
from a place of scarcity and thirst and
this need to oh I got I got to take and
take and I don't care about the
consequences you're going to have a
rocky road and you you know if you're
successful you're still not going to be
fulfilled whereas if your intent is
positive and I want everyone to win with
me and I'm doing coming from a place of
abundance you will be infinitely more
successful and fulfilled that that ni
that intent with which we approach a
task is so important and Islam
conceptualizes it with the term that
everyone knows about oh yeah that's Nia
took me 30 something years to work out
the importance of intent and my Muslim
brothers are like oh yeah Nia no big
deal we know about this it's written
written hundreds of years ago there's so
much guidance within Islam it's amazing
it really isul so what are the some of
the things you use cuz you're you're
trained in reading people what are some
of the secrets that you have on how to
read people yeah so my my experience
within um with within uh the
intelligence World um you you get
trained in something called human
intelligence so that that's effectively
being able to
interact uh fairly consciously but still
the execution is naturally um so that
you can recruit and handle agents and
sources to go and collect information
for you do things for you um so you're
you're in a very objective focused way
winning friends and influencing people
you know to to put it simply uh and
different things go into that
essentially any any young man who's
seeking or young woman who's seeking to
know how to read people and build
relationships effectively you need to
increase your emotional and social
intelligence and there there's many
resources out there um I don't agree
with things like NLP or any of these
sort of tricks or games especially if
you're dealing with members of the elite
you're not going to NLP a billionaire
I'm sorry he has a um what's a h way to
put it a bull crap is that that's fair
right um radar that works yeah so you're
not going to trick especially you know
successful important people but if you
can really develop your self-awareness
your social awareness your emotional
intelligence and then you can look at
things like micro Expressions if you
want that that that's real So reading
someone's emotional leakage uh
essentially through a h hyper focus on
on someone's face and their tone and
their body language see whether they're
congruent or not if they're not then
perhaps there's an agenda there so that
there's things you can read up on but
for me the main thing
is if if you want to be effective at
building relationships
you just need to be very self-aware very
socially aware like one one example if
you're dealing with for example a leader
of a country or a leader of a large
business someone's very time poor you
need to understand how important their
time is and you need to be really
efficient with your Communications a lot
of people who haven't interacted with
people like that they got no idea how
busy that person is and they just hey
man how are you no yeah what do you want
yeah forget the pleasantries be be
polite but be efficient like knowing how
to communicate effectively and
respectfully with very time poor people
with important people with the elite
that brings real benefits so yeah anyone
who wants to be good at reading people
and and building
relationships there's a lot of books a
lot of references out there just focus
on improving your social awareness your
your etiquette like do you know how to
sit down in a fine dining situation and
in a way that looks natural follow the
conventions that come with fine dining a
lot of business is done over over dinner
you need to be good with these things in
terms of dress do you know how to dress
in a way that shows you understand the
rules that go with dressing in a classic
classy fashion like all these Unwritten
rules that come with being uper Society
you can study them you can learn them
yeah um and so I know I'm segueing
slightly um because I think reading
people is is a good thing I mean you can
go and read about you know interrogation
and the way you know police and and
other people will analyze someone when
they're interviewing you can go down
that path if you want but I think the
end State we all want is how to build
Rel relationships effectively with
people who are useful and can add value
to our life a lot of that comes down to
your cultural capital so understanding
what is it that wealthy people talk
about can you talk about these things
too uh understanding as I said the
social graces of upper Society whether
it's dinner going to someone's house
parties um you know things like don't
rock up empty-handed always bring a gift
all these sorts of things the unwritten
rules that come with being a member of
uper Society these are things you can
study and learn and and I think any any
young person who wants to fit into upper
society would do well to learn how to
dress learn find dining etiquette learn
how to communicate efficiently and
clearly and respectfully uh with very
time po people learn how to carry
yourself in a way where you're
displaying the value that you can bring
to them whether it's practical value or
or you know other forms once you build
that relationship more the sort of
emotional mental value it's a it's a
skill you can develop like anything else
yeah but and I think people will do well
to consciously try and increase their
self-awareness increase their social
intelligence increase their emotional
intelligence I don't see that being
taught that often everyone's like you
know go and learn this go and learn that
then you'll be successful it's like
people run the world right you learn to
run people you learn to run at least
your world um and you can consciously
learn to access uper society and
interact with them effectively I mean
I'm an example of that I came from
absolutely nothing I didn't eat in a
nice restaurant till my 20s mid 20s even
as I went into the intelligence world I
remember sitting down when I was
actually recruited in the intelligence
world and it was like a six or seven
course dinner I was like this is
ridiculous they keep bringing stuff out
like I had no idea didn't really know
how to dress I I had to get taught how
to dress when I went into this
intelligence world just this soldier
from a welfare family who had no idea
how to dress normally these sorts of
things so it's there's skills you can
learn and and now alhamdulillah I I have
many important friends and clients and
and I fit into those rooms with with you
know the elite and I came from nothing
so it is a skill you can learn it just
takes conscious practice and take some
time I think again without rambling too
much I think especially young men of
today would do well to learn to dress
well and Tristan's talked about this
Tristan said one of his goals is to
inspire young men to dress well there's
a reason for that when you have you know
a classic navy suit for example or let's
say a jacket a Navy Blazer which is
nicely cut to your body you know quality
fabric a nice crisp white shirt with a
nice sharp collar and just some um sand
col or or Kaki chinos with some nice
medium brown penny loafers
you are projecting a bit of a uniform
that signifies class and refinement and
understanding the rules and if you want
to go on you can personalize it and
break the rules a bit as long as you do
it in an appropriate manner but simply
by learning to dress well as as a young
man who's going out and whether it's
doing a job interview or whe whether
looking to get funding for you know a
project You're Building knowing how to
dress well projects a lot of value like
if if you want to start with a simple
easy way to bring High Roi learn how to
dress in a very classic refined manner
you're projecting value into the room
without saying anything so that's a good
place to start I wanted to touch on that
earlier point you made about influencing
people it reminds me of of how a lot of
prophets most of them became prophets
after the age of 40 most of them right
and most of them many of them were
herters of animals before people oh wow
because if you can't influence the
flocks of animals how are you going to
influence people because the thing with
the the nature of herds of animals and
livestock is they like to disperse so
they role of a herder is to kind of
unite them into One Direction isn't that
interesting amazing isn't that amazing
yeah and I think a lot of people focus
on the technical skills and I get that
learn to be a doctor lawyer businessman
so on learn the technical aspects of
jobs but let's face it that the people I
know who are hyper successful I think we
can all agree they may be technically
competent but where they stand out is
their ability to interact effectively
with other people to motivate people to
get on board and support them to help
them to work for them and so on the
concentrated Focus especially as a young
man on people skills which is increasing
self-awareness social intelligence
emotional intelligence understanding the
unwritten rules of of interacting with
upper Society understanding cultural
capital and how to develop it can you
talk about whether it's saling or art or
or you know the the families that are
running the hospitality industry in your
city or you know a certain conglomerate
making a certain move in in the state
you're in do you understand what the
elite are talking about educate yourself
in that area that will greatly improve
your success there's direct correlation
with with being able to be in such
circles and benefit as a result because
man when you get accepted into the the
circles of the elite money is easy for
the people at the Top If you can add
value to an ultrath high worth ultra
high net worth individual and then go on
to build a relationship with them one of
the things they do well is making money
they will bring you in whether it's a
property deal or an Ico or an IPO or
some sort of startup if you are friend
with people at the elite and you've
added value to their life they're going
to want to add value back and the way to
do that is say hey why don't you invest
in this this project or what you might
want to get a piece of this talk to this
guy you might want to invest in that
that's where I've made the most money in
this world wow it's through access to
investments from my friends who are a
lot better with money than I could ever
be so I think anyone who who wants to do
well in life put that time and effort
into knowing how to belong in the room
and add value to members of the elite
amazing that's amazing so look the part
know what to talk about
have emotional and social intelligence
and voice messages under two minutes
ideally not voice messages at all man
good like the amount of I joke about
this with with Tate and a few other you
know very time poor people the amount of
people who say hey can we jump on a call
if I said yes to all the people saying
hey can we jump on a call that's
literally all I do and and people are 10
times 100 times busier than me I don't
know how leaders of countries or someone
like Tate does it and and that's why
like the idea long voice notes that's
rude to somebody because because you're
expecting them to sit there for 40
seconds a minute some people don't have
that quick efficient type message bof
that's it now I find people who aren't
used to being that time poor might find
that a bit rude oh what he won't even
listen to a two-minute voice message is
that I think you're rude for expecting
that I will like it it's little things
like this you need to learn this with
the ultra high net worth and the ultra
busy in the world don't go sending them
voice messages or asking for a call very
clearly and concisely say what it is
that you want cuz their business they
want to get that done and move on to the
next task so ideally they can get some
sleep at some point abely so what's your
take on why a lot of people in the west
don't want to have kids now or delaying
kids for the sake of
dun I I think we're living in a world in
ter oh the West is is
is I think the West is is hyper
masculine I think in in terms of its
focus on what matters like women are
trying to be masculine men are focused
on you know Conquest even if they aren't
that masculine nowadays I I think the um
there's a loss of recognition of the
importance of the role of the feminine
wow and a big part of the role of the
feminine is creating a beautiful safe
space with which to bring in and raise
children I think it's greatly
undervalued I think it's disrespected a
woman nowadays if she wants to be at
stay-at home mom is looked down upon by
someone else who's slaving away for a
corporation that doesn't care for them
so I think an unfortunate side product
of this I don't think it's materialism I
just think right we're all meant to be
equal men and women are meant to work
where's there room for the feminine CU
if you want to succeed for example in
the corporate world you need to be pushy
disagreeable assertive organized Good
Under Pressure hungry for status hungry
to push more these are masculine traits
and if everyone is trying to exhibit
these traits the the soft gentle art of
being a feminine nurturing giving
caregiver like it just sort of gets gets
run over and I think that's why we are
where we are I think it's a a very sad
state but I think women are all trying
to be men and men are confused as to
what they are and as a result society's
just oh well I guess we should do what
we're told which is go to UNI then get a
job then work hard and maybe when I'm 40
then I'll have time for a
kid it's dangerous healthwise too the
way women are having kids later and
later there there a real risk involved
for the child so I think it's a very sad
State of Affairs and again I think think
any woman who chooses to be a mother and
chooses to find a man she can be looked
after by I think it's a beautiful thing
and I think there's no shame in at all I
think it should be celebrated not viewed
as a negative and the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he he always told us
that I will be proud of my um that you
know expands and increases for they will
increase Islam in the um in numbers and
Allah even says in the Quran you know do
not kill your children out of fear of
poverty at the end of the day like have
kids and rely on me I will provide I'm a
I'm the one that gives the risk the the
provisioning not you you know so too
many people take it into their own hands
and I think Western capitalism it almost
there's two problems one is it's too
self-centered so it's selfish it makes
it's all about me you know forget kids
it's about me my life my journey my
Independence my freedom my happiness and
then the second thing is it puts too
much of an emphasis on how expensive it
is and at the end of the day we as
Muslims we don't believe in that that's
an interesting one I think I mean
raising kids is a lot of work U there's
no doubt about about that and I think
when you're in a society where it's all
about the individual why would you make
those sacrifices why would you do that
work and also I think in a situation
where you don't have the belief in Allah
where you really think your life is all
on you man that'd be stressful in terms
of
money I can remember when I was uh
raising my my kids um at one point they
were they were both in nursery and that
was before they got to school and school
my company would pay I was paying I
think 12 or $133,000 each each year for
un uh for for nursery for 4 hours a day
if you wanted them in longer then you
had to pay extra like for for numerous
years of my life I didn't save a scent
it was all going into my kids like it is
difficult financially and if you don't
have a belief in in Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
providing that I think that's just a
risk a lot of westerners don't want to
take it's just it's just too scary m
protect us man so forgive me for
backtracking but I wanted to ask this
questions just y'all kept going I was
like let me just be patient you had
mentioned something about NLP that you
couldn't like
NLP uh some guy who is very well versed
in like spotting things what is NP
neural linguistic programming was a
system that was produced in order to try
and replicate as I understand it the
traits of the elite or of successful
people and bring in certain strategies
with which to influence them to to
essentially view you
favorably I could draw I could draw some
correlations with for example like
pickup Artistry except NLP would be the
sort of nonsexual version having some
techniques and tricks to make people
like you for example but again as with
pickup Artistry and this is why I'm
against all of this stuff and and always
have been it's only going to work with a
very low caliber of person no no high
quality virtuous woman is going to fall
for the tricks of some pickup artist
it's not real you know what I mean
someone with a bunch of trauma and
someone you know perhaps seeking some
sort of validation and who has low
morals she might fall for the pickup
Artistry but quality women won't it's
the same thing with things like NLP or
trying to game a billionaire it's not
going to work high value people will see
right through it will think you're
socially awkward W have anything to do
with you so yeah all this NLP all this
pickup Artistry stuff develop yourself
as a high value person with capabilities
with specialist skill sets with a
network who can add value to an
important person's life that's how you
go out and build relationships plus all
the social and emotional intelligence
and cultural capital we talked about not
learning tricks and techniques and and
game or NLP that'll be my answer there
brother I really do think like this the
whole pickup Artistry thing which kind
of moved into the red pill thing which
kind of moved into the manosphere thing
it's all junk it's all genuine junk like
okay that stuff might work on on low
class women but if you're looking to
build quality and fulfilling
relationships why do you want to game
someone why do you want to trick someone
for what to to get naked with them for
what for what purpose it's all just junk
so yeah I I I continue to challenge
anyone who buys into this pickup
Artistry or manosphere or red pill stuff
look at the credibility of the sources
of the information the people who are
telling you hey this is how you do
relationships what are their
relationships like you know what what
people who are trying to teach you about
dating and all this sort of
stuff what what grounds do they have to
do that the the internet has brought on
the the the age of the self-appointed
expert and unfortunately a lot of people
listen to these self-appointed experts
so I just I think it's anyone who who
thinks red pill has value to add to your
life I mean yes if you were in a
relationship where you were being
exploited by a female partner red pill
can help you be aware of the negative
traits that can be exhibited by women
and you see a lot in the west I get that
but in terms of solution in terms of
answers there's nothing in that space
and indeed the people pushing it don't
have any credibility or receipts with
which to do it Islam however the green
pill that has very clear guidance that
has very clear answers and also has
advice on the potential Dark Side of
women that you should be aware of and
the Dark Side of men as well Ian it's
all covered in the Quran I mean I don't
know whether we should say it but I have
seen the Hellfire and the majority of
souls in it are ungrateful
women we've heard this right like it's
and what they're saying there is women
have the potential to become ungrateful
and you can see why throughout history a
woman would survive through a man
providing and and protecting for her she
had to survive through taking from a man
so the downside is that is they can take
that for granted that that's natural men
have a dark side as well and that's
talked about even more in the Quran the
fact that men can be greedy the fact
that men can be violent and unempathetic
you know the Quran gives a lot of
guidance for women as to you know the
red flags in men as well so I think
everything forget all this red pill
stuff and on the other side forget all
this feminist stuff the answers as to
the potential dark sides and red flags
to look out for in man and wom is in the
Quran and the solutions as to how to
create balanced respectful sustainable
relationships with practical foundation
not just oh I feel something when he
looks at me or she looks at me you know
that emotional nonsense pushed by
Western culture that is all in the Quran
as well the green pill is so vastly
Superior to any red pill or any other
pill out there to me it's it's just the
most natural way to live it is the truth
it is the answer when it comes to
relationships you know in
Islam in the Quran Allah
says he's speaking about the story of uh
Maham Moses
mhm and he was talking about the time
where MSA had left and he was gone from
his people for amount of time okay and
during this time the people ended up
basically worshiping the CF like the cow
okay and bro some still do
yeah
bro and when he came back I I worship C
and I'm meeting we we eat some good wagu
in this house right that's my form of
worship that was W you not sh yeah of
course there's free flowing wagu in this
house man I grew up eating nothing but
chicken boiled chicken grilled chicken I
can't even eat eat chicken anymore we
could never afford red meat Growing Up
Now alhamdulillah free flowing wagu
steak delivered every day that's why
tast so
good you guys are welcome there's
unlimited Wago in this house sorry to
interrupt it's okay let's stop talking
about worshiping
C so these people they were worshiping
the cows and mus he was very very upset
and then Allah basically told them to
tell them that okay you know what know
that you did wrong repent and then
basically off off the people that were
doing this and if you think about this
think about just really think about this
the prophet
Muhammad the prophet Muhammad sallahu
alaihi wasallam the red pools aren't
working right now bro again man keep
going
more the answer is always more so sleep
sleep next week bro bro listen the
prophet mammad sah alai wasam said that
the umah is one body and that when one
part of it is hurting then all of it is
hurting interesting and if you think
about the human biology the human body
we're just made up of a whole bunch of
cells MH and these cells if you think
okay if if my cells here are affected
it's affecting everything else that's
the opposite of individualism thinking
about the whole Community if some are
suffering all are suffering amazing so
look at that okay if if I have a problem
here it's going to affect me everywhere
if I have a problem my heart it's going
to affect me everywhere now if that's
how the umah of the the Muslims is
imagine the um of the entire human
population the human world now look at
things like red pill MH look at things
like feminism look at things like pickup
pickup Artistry and all this stuff well
listen this stuff is so disgusting it is
all right these people let me tell you
these people I hate to say it like this
but actually I won't even say let you
kind of like use your imagination and go
like that but there's we were all
talking about this one guy who he's a a
pickup artist and he he made this guide
and the guide was basically how
to pick up can I pull this up huh can I
pull this up pull pull it up please it's
disgusting bro listen this is what what
red pill has gotten into okay you need
to see this there's a group chat that
I'm in with uh this one YouTuber by the
name of Abu American soal brother you
know I haven't met him but we've talked
good my he makes a lot proper masculine
Islamic you know content and let me see
this he's the sort of guy you want on
your team he's a real 100% 100% so taken
you see this picture right M so this is
what was posted by a red pill pickup
artist all right on Twitter just listen
to this corrupting religious girls a
guide oh for straight to J floor listen
religion is is a scam we all know this
but those drawn to it are submissive by
nature and in women that is a useful
trait to us so when you meet a nice bird
who happens to be an a cult how do you
become her new
God so it's like they're they're
basically making video who's the person
this this person Christopher Zephyr on X
so anyway you click on this right let me
guess he's some geek withing
relationship deleted the Tweet of course
he did yeah and it's like we're just
talking about how he picture of a hijab
for that for the shock Factor so some
fights you don't want to pick man be
smarter than that like honestly that's
disgusting for it's funny cuz he said
religious people are are submissive by
Nature he doesn't know what Muslims
would do to him he has no idea what the
Muslim guys would do to him but also on
that point of
submissiveness for a woman to submit to
a man takes courage you're in a position
of vulnerability for a man to submit to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala takes courage
you need to put your ego aside and say
you know what I'm not the biggest
hottest whatever there's something much
greater than me and I submit to that I
think submission is an act of strength
if anything when it's done in a healthy
way with with good near I don't I don't
see any weakness in it whatsoever no
man tempted to you know we found this we
found this man I had the same reaction
we had the same reaction he has 400
followers on Twitter yeah he's said
nobody no one bro this is no one but the
point is was coming after T to I wanted
to bring it up the way I wanted to bring
it up is to say that this is what
happens in the body sometimes in the
body we get like a cancer cell right now
if you fast you will enter a state of
autophagy and in the state of autophagy
the body is literally it's basically the
strong Only the Strong Survive so all
the weak cells are dying off if you have
cancer cells they're dying off
so there's another process as well
called apoptosis where it's it's
literally the cell death the the cell is
killing itself mhm and bro these people
like this yeah it's true actually that's
a very good point man this is the thing
like a lot of people get angry at
whether it's haters or it's um you know
people like this we have to remind
ourselves cuz my response is anger as
well and I have certain capabilities
like anyway but what we need to remind
ourselves is these people are already
being punished yeah people who are
talking about pickup Artistry targeting
religious women people are talking about
whether it's extreme feminists or you
know the extreme red pill stuff their
lives are miserable
you know the haters out there their
lives are miserable if you're living a
good productive life you don't have time
to spew hate and negativity from behind
a keyboard these people are already
being punished there's no point throwing
hate or anger at them Allah subhana wa
ta'ala is giving them what they deserve
already we don't have to do anything
their lives are the punishment now we
can pray for them show them compassion
hope that they find a more meaningful
you know positive way to live but man
all the people doing this sort of
nonsense out there you know the the
feminist red pill types their lives are
the punishment it's very clear and if
they don't repent Allah go them then
Allah will deal with them justly W it's
a very it's a very low life just like
they're a slave to their desires like
they're upset that men and women submit
to God it's like you're submitting to
your desire you're basically I'm sorry
you're like a dog that's a good point
they're submitting to dopamine they're
submitting to porn addictions they're
submitting to all sorts of things we are
submitting to the Creator who has a very
clear guide with which to us with which
for us to follow a day-to-day existence
in order to live a a clean Halal
existence which when you were living it
when you
onim is a beautiful state to live in
it's it's ah it's amazing I love it so
yeah let let Unfortunately they are
their own Punisher you know they they
are destroying their own lives so let
them do it but
man I wouldn't mind having a little face
to face chat with
that so quick question remind us how old
are you I'm 41 41 My Bro 4 when years
young how do you have the vitality and
vigor to go dayto day having more energy
more aggressiveness and assertiveness
than a lot of 20-year-olds unfortunately
that I see today yeah I have more energy
than I have when I was 20 that's for
sure without question and I think yeah
again as a as a as a younger man i' I'd
look at high performing people think oh
I wish I had that
motivation when you develop a certain
amount of capability and every minute of
your day can be spent on positive impact
for your people on on building business
that that are meaningful and employ
people and bring money when you can
spend every minute of your day learning
something which blows your mind such as
you know our faith you realize you don't
have time to waste I think as a young
man you think I got all the time in the
world it doesn't matter man Warren
Buffett he talks about this apparently
when people would write to Warren
Buffett and say Hey you want an hour of
your time he said look if I live to the
average age of 80 something that means I
have 250 for example hours left of my
you know working days why should I give
you one of those hours so his response
is I call it you know momento Mori being
aware of your morality knowing you have
a finite time on this planet man young
people you don't have time to waste like
there was a point in my life maybe 30 or
so when I went from thinking I've got
all the Time in the World to do whatever
I want to thinking hang on how many more
adventures with the lads do I have if I
do a couple of year while I'm still
physically healthy I've got
maybe 30 or 40 to go I need to make each
Adventure count I need to map out all
the incredible Adventures I want to have
with my Lads in this beautiful world
which which you know we're blessed to to
be experiencing before I perish and I
need to crack on and get these done like
I think young people need to be have
more of a sense of urgency they need to
be more aware of the fact that your time
and your health and your energy is
finite don't waste a single day because
man it could all be gone tomorrow like
people you know there's skulls in my
house I I don't worship them you know
it's not sh they are there to remind me
of our mortality that death can be
coming tomorrow you do not have time to
waste you must get the most out of every
day and what is that it's learning you
know it's practicing Islam as as well as
you can it's contributing to to your
brothers to your family to to your
businesses you don't have a single day
to waste you don't have a single moment
to waste and I think as you get older
you realize that more and more but also
your capabilities increase 1 hour of my
time now I can bring about so much more
benefit to people's Liv you know those
who are mentoring to to my staff those
who are I'm coaching and lifting up U to
to in terms of financially I can bring
in a lot of money in an hour when I was
20 I didn't have that capability so time
didn't seem as valuable time didn't seem
as finite but if you can as a young
person grasp the fact that your time is
a finite thing your health is a finite
thing and you need to make the most out
of every day you'll find the motivation
because you don't have time to waste you
you you cannot afford to be anything but
your best self giving your best effort
every single moment of every day you
just don't have time to waste and you
tend to realize that as you get older
yeah that answers your question you know
you actually remind me of two oh there
it is just written yeah um firstly the
prophet he said take take advantage of
five things before five things he said
your your youth before old age he said
time before you you become busy
um Health before illness and a few other
things alhamdulillah Subhan Allah so
yeah there it is again one of the things
I like I mean if we want to talk a bit
of detail about my experience as a
Reverb after I pray and and my my focus
at first was fully understanding The
Words of the prayer like fully
understanding what I'm saying and
reading the history behind that and and
afterwards and I find that to be very
very fulfilling but each time after I
pray I I I ask Allah subhana tala to
protect and guide my family and and my
brothers and everyone I care about I ask
that those who are suffering in the
world find peace in their hearts through
Islam and also I I focus on health I I I
sit there and I feel that my I'm not in
pain or if I am in pain you know it's
not too bad I I give thanks for the fact
that I'm not sick and broken because
I've been broken before I've dealt with
chronic pain for years that's that
teaches you something man like every day
we are not in pain that's a blessing so
multiple times a day I give thanks for
that and I suggest everyone else do it
like don't be like me and break your
back in multiple places to realize how
important your health is you know like
any day you are not in pain is a
beautiful day to be alive I think that's
something we all need to be aware of I
know it's a bit of a tangent but um it's
something I think is really important
yeah I mean every time we get sick even
it's a sore throat when you swallow you
feel it you think yourself oh man if
only I appreciated when I when I could
swallow and it would didn't hurt and I
love that it's written of course it's
written what what isn't what important
piece of wisdom or guidance in life is
not written in our faith it's remarkable
Islam literally encompasses everything
that's why it's a Dean that's why it's a
full way of life alhamdulillah and the
second Hadith uh that that you reminded
me of was prophet he said remember often
the the destroyer of all pleasures
meaning death oh wow cuz think about it
you know you're like oh I want to get
this car I want to go on this yacht I
want to fly here I want to do this I
want to go on this trip I want to be
with these people and you you you feel
happy when you think of doing these
things and when you're doing them this
moment you think about I'm going to be
dead I'm going to be 6 feet under none
of that really matters anymore it's like
obviously you want to exper when you're
alive you want you want to be able to do
these things but when you remember death
you're like man you know it really hits
close to home and you remember okay well
what comes after death exactly there it
is amazing and I think that that I love
that it's written so the concept of
moment Mor already existed in Islam I
love it I think if you can if you can
keep that in mind the fact that you're
going to be dust one day what are you
going to look back on on your deathbed
and with the most fondness it's not
going to be the cars it's not going to
be the Jets it's not going to be the
Yachts man these things are better you
know on Instagram than they are in real
life bro I've flown first class more
times than I can count it's just a seat
on an airplane like after a while it
gives you zero Buzz why does hedonistic
adaptation happen why do you get sick of
you know fine meals or luxury
experiences or Fine Cars cuz it's all
meaningless what are some things you
can't get sick of you can't get sick of
Salah you can't get sick of time spent
with your brothers and your family in
good conversations you can't get sick of
seeing your child get better at a task
or applying themselves to you can't get
sick of helping your staff and the
people who rely on you live better lives
like to me it's so clear I mean it's
easier to say once you've mastered money
and done mastered once you've achieved
enough in terms of money and done all
the luxury experiences to say this stuff
doesn't really matter but I can tell you
with with full intent I have more money
than I could ever need what matters most
what would my ideal be day be would have
nothing to do with flashy luxury it
would have nothing to do with money it
would be spending
time
would be spending time with my brothers
my family doing meaningful work hitting
the gym going to the mused that's what
life is about you don't need all this
other stuff W you don't need it so yeah
I think if if younger people can keep
that in mind at an early age and and try
and
live as to what matters because one day
you'll be dead and avoid all the all the
I mean we talk about thirst traps on
Instagram I think there's a lot of daa
traps oh but you should have this car oh
you should be going this yard oh you
should do I mean look I do a lot of this
stuff sure but I'm not attached to it
and I see through it I don't think it's
important I don't think it's anything to
Aspire to experience it sure but don't
Define yourself as a human with it yeah
if you as a young man can keep in mind
one day you're going to be dead certain
things matter certain things don't
Western culture doesn't understand that
so reject all that and focus on what
really matters time with your people
doing well everyone winning together
your faith you're going to live a better
life but I think people are pulled in so
many different directions especially
with Western culture with with social
media all these things yeah yeah I think
a great something I really do appreciate
is is you seem to take a keen focus on
investing in people helping transform
people making their lives better this is
this is what the prophet did with the
people the sahabah you know he he he
transformed them like none else and then
he used these people to you know to
teach Islam to push Islam to to teach
others about the religion and to to
bring more Muslims and these are people
he sent as Messengers to other nations
to speak to like you know the elite the
world class and all that stuff and and
and he changed the whole world and with
the people that he inspired and he
taught they changed like imagine
om he conquered like Rome and
Persia these these amazing people that
spread Islam to like the borders of
China around the whole globe and today
you know the the fastest growing
religionallah projections say soon Islam
will be the largest religion in the
world all because one man invested in
the team who transformed others isn't
that amazing isn't that amazing and I
can understand that that the
satisfaction of winning with your
brothers it beats look I I've had
Investments that pop and make a lot of
money all right cool I've had projects
with brothers that have worked made a
lot less money but have been 10 times
more fulfilling winning with your people
seeing them when especially the brothers
who need it financially that's more
meaningful than just more money in the
bank winning together as a team is such
a fulfilling thing and that's why I take
so much care with the people I Mentor
with with my staff in the various
businesses that that I'm involved in I I
take great care and pride in seeing them
win and for me that's the flex I've got
enough stuff I've done enough cool
things but for example one of my staff
members who can now afford to buy
himself you know instead of a you know a
broken down Honda he's in a you know a
nice new Toyota prao what a fantastic
win that's more meaningful than me
getting another Ferrari I get more
satisfaction from having facilitated or
enabled his win than than I would more
stuff like that winning together as
brothers that's a special kind of magic
it's it's it's powerful 100% it's funny
you mention that because I remember
distinctly when we did the first podcast
back in February that was honestly I
think the best one we we we ever did
personally my favorite or one of my
favorites and it didn't matter to me
when it had 20,000 views or when it had
2 million it did not mean w it did not
make a difference I think we spoke about
that as well and I told you guys I'm
like you know 50k whatever 2 million
even before like publishing it when we
were at sh's house I was like it didn't
mean anything the fact it together and
that we could help other people with it
that that that's why it matter and
that's that's the honest intent too and
that's why I think there's a lot of
people who focused on getting that cash
if you can just focus on adding value
doing meaningful work with people you
respect the cash is going to come yeah
the cash comes and if if again if you're
neara if the intent in your heart is I
want to use my time on this planet to
bring a positive impact on my family my
brothers on my community you're going to
do all right you're going to be fine you
know
bro it's sorry I know I'm not I'm
talking way too much but it's crazy
mention that as well because me and the
guys we had a chat very recently before
this trip and we're like we we need to
fix up we need to go our attention
straight again we need to make sure
we're only doing things for the sake of
Allah we're not just trying to get
people to click we're trying to inspire
people you know do da for the sake of
Allah awesome as soon as we did that you
hit us up you're like okay let's make it
happen uh we have all these plans in in
America with Ali dawa and like all these
people calling literally like as soon as
we change our intentions like it reminds
me brother Simon said yesterday on the
podcast shout out to Simon Says squat on
Instagram he said that you must become
the person first before Allah gives you
the things that that person is worthy of
so it's like if you want all these
things but you don't get it right now
don't think that the arrow is not coming
from Allah if Allah Wills it's coming
your way but it's just not time yet but
you haven't grown into that person yet
and when you do inshallah Allah will
always overd deliver and maybe I mean
again the
prophet he suffered a lot and he was
God's favorite you know if that's an
accurate way to put it you think you
don't need to suffer a bit before you're
a ma man of course you do Embrace that
suffering Tate speaks to that really
well embrace the struggle embrace the
war you need it as as your path as a man
to becoming the the best man that you
can be to best look after your people
it's necessary yeah I mean the prophet
wasam you know he even like I think
before R relation came he he was a
person who took care of Orphans he he
was orphaned as a kid it's like where do
you think that empathy and that love and
that compassion comes from it came from
him being tested came from him knowing
what it's like to be at the bottom
knowing what it's like to to lose your
parents to lose your children to to lose
your friends your family to fight
battles and win F battles and lose to be
rich to be poor he lived every kind of
life and and you know of course he was
the most empathetic the most caring was
and a lot of people I think especially
those who don't understand Islam they
don't understand yes the prophet was a
warrior yes he was a Stern leader when
he needed to be manag multiple families
you know huge huge body of people he was
was deeply EMP empathetic he was deeply
compassionate he showed Mercy in ways
that very few people would have the
restraint to show Mercy he was actually
a very caring very careful man when it
came to his people I don't think people
outside of Islam fully understand that
they just see this sort of harsh Warrior
type figure who who conquered a lot it's
it's very far from the truth he was a he
was a beautifully empathetic and
compassionate
man it's amazing stuff like as as a
foreigner who grew up again within the
mil I joined the military you know as
soon as I could as a teenager um my view
of Islam was definitely negative again I
I wasn't ignorant enough to think that
Muslims were the enemy but I definitely
thought Islam is dangerous and you know
it's a religion that inv involves full
submission and and you know it can lead
to extremism all these sorts of things
but when you fully understand Islam
properly and you research it
properly all of those mistruths are
instantly dispelled it's all about
compassion it's about again for for
those who think Islam is somehow
negative or extremist every single
action you take you are accountable to a
higher Force everything like if if
someone truly believes that they're
going to be a good person they have to
be they are forced to be by the the the
structure for life that is Islam so yeah
if I can go from being a soldier who
views Muslims as you know sort of scary
and and potentially dangerous to
actually taking shahada you know 15
years later there's no reason for for
anyone to not put in the time and the
the learning to realize how much value
and Truth there is in this religion if
if I can come from that to this anyone
else can you know it's it's so real so
what would you tell someone who they
don't really know much about
Islam you know what advice would you
give them or better yet what advice
would you give yourself if you would to
be taken back in time I mean to myself
I'd say look you're a a man who's driven
for truth and pursuing masculine
Excellence all these things that you
learning over time through trial and
error or already written so just go and
read them that's what I'd say to myself
um but what I'd say to to people who
perhaps are considering Islam or or or
you know are just watching this and
thinking you know what what what's the
big deal why is everyone talking about
this so much um what if there was a
truth and and a system that came from
that truth which by following it made
you the most fulfilled and most
effective and best human you could be to
then serve your family your your
brothers your community to to leave the
most positive impact that you can on the
world what if there was a clear guidance
for every area of life that was the most
natural and most beneficial way to
navigate through life to resist
temptation to make healthy decisions to
live in that optimal state of of a
higher frequency high output ethical
moral State what if that exists no
matter where you are in life
culture wealth age that would make you a
better person right that would improve
your life make you better make you
better for your people it does exist
it's called
Islam so anyone who's sort of thinking
how do I become a better person how do I
be you know what how do I navigate the
decisions of Life where's the guidance
and the structure and the meaning that
everyone wants we have these questions
in us we all have these deeper questions
what's the purpose of life how we meant
to live it's written and it's clear and
from personal experience as someone who
had no love for organized religion
growing up this works it's real you can
sense it on a both logical and an
emotional level it is incredibly
powerful incredibly real so to anyone
who's considering Islam you will be a
better person and better able to look
after your people with it wherever you
are in life so why not put the time and
energy in to learn about it properly and
inshallah say those those powerful words
sh you can train your body to to put up
with anything right and and one of the
things you can train your body to do is
to sleep less I don't necessarily think
it's a good thing I think if you can get
you know 8 hours sleep great but man
I've gone for years of my life with 4
hour sleep and I'm the sort of guy who
likes sleep but if you got work to do if
you got something to build if you're
looking to change where you are in life
you're not going to be able to do it
with a nice rested approach that's a
reality I'm sorry if if you want to take
yourself from here at the bottom of the
societal ladder and and you know join
the elite and and live well and be able
to give good to cat and look after your
people you're going to have to be tired
sometimes suck it up get on with it like
it's a it's a real thing you know yeah
for a long time I used to feel like I
needed 9 10 11 sometimes 12 hours of
sleep I be Einstein re Einstein required
12 hours of sleep so you can justify it
right can you imagine affording that
luxury bro oh my got what once a week I
try and get a full eight hours that's my
goal once a week and what's what are the
rest typically
it depends like my meetings start at 10:
tomorrow and they go all day until the
evening and someone will probably call
me at 8:30 like so I I'll get a good
solid 3 4 hours tonight but at the end
of the day like if you're doing
meaningful work and you're looking after
your people and you're with men you
respect doing purposeful things you
don't really want to sleep anyway like
you don't want to sleep you got stuff to
do so it's it's it's a different
frequency cuz if you feel you need 10
hour sleep then you will need 10 hours
sleep if you feel ah I got so much to do
and I'm so excited by it all and and and
I know that I'm living a good life and
having a positive impact on everyone
around me you want to be doing that
sleeping sleeping doesn't help you that
well that's what I'm saying is that I
felt that
before and just recently I'd say
honestly just this trip and of itself we
went from well I went from Paris to
Mecca mhm all right pause pause pause
you went from Paris to
Mecca right right par to jeda par to
jeda I went from St Louis I drove all
the way I'm I'm showing you guys how we
met right so you took a flight from
Paris to jeda how long was the flight
honestly I don't
remember it was about I think 7 hours I
drove from St Louis Missouri in the mid
damn West all the way to Houston Texas
which was I think a 14-hour drive right
bad then I took not bad just getting
fired up and then I took a flight from
Houston Texas to to meet on right no I
didn't but on the flight were you
driving I I drove all the way to on the
flight you could just sleep you could
relax yeah yeah yeah so I flew from
Houston Texas to Dubai four hour layover
and Dubai to jeda then I met an right
what time did we get there
bro uh we got there really late we got
there at 4:00 a.m. you know what we did
after this whole like almost 48 Hours of
traveling we did umra nice no sleep nice
that's cool we did um we came back I
think we slept 2 hours went to a new
hotel did more I around the Haram next
night I think we slept another like 2 3
hours right we got here to Dubai every
single night we've been sleeping how
long
sometimes basically the sleep cycles
have been like around 3 hours or so
hours and then last night was the first
night that we actually got like a decent
amount of sleep me too I I got a
sleeping last night that's what I'm
saying when you message like oh like
Lads I want to just uh get some sleep I
was like alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
isn't it funny when you haven't slept
for a while and you get a prop a night
sleep you wake up and you're like what
happened like it's a different thing
it's different right I actually feel
more tired today yeah know what I'm
saying that's what I noticed is that
with less sleep like let's say I'm
getting maybe two cycles of three hours
or just one cycle of 6 hours it's more
than
enough it's more than enough like I I
don't feel tired and then when night
time comes it's like okay I'm ready to
go to sleep whereas if I get more than 6
hours by night time I'm like yo like
let's keep going like let's stay up yeah
you're good bro and you can push you can
push to anything like um when I was
evacuating families from Ukraine at one
point I drove for 42 43 hours in a row
wow In and Out In and Out in and out
back and forth you know long lines to uh
by the end of it I was like straight
hallucinating like the um street lights
they were drawing these lines you know
in the Star Wars movie you know when it
goes into hyperdrive and they that that
was happening as I was driving I like
okay this is different and you know like
I was hallucinating I'd shake it out I'd
still see I was like yeah this I need to
sleep but you're not going to stop
helping people in situations like that
drink K in fast it does my God I'm
buzzing momy take a siy take a SI bro
we're going to start the I'm broken I
can drink two more cups two more cans
and nothing I promise let's let's get
you three
then my point is the human body can push
through things you wouldn't believe it's
just knowing you can do it and just
having a reason to just crack on now
I don't recommend I've I've worked to
the point where I've had health issues I
don't recommend that but also at the end
of the day I don't know anyone who's
really changed their life situation
comfortably I don't know anyone who's
really built an Empire and it hasn't
involved them pretty much ruining
themselves for a couple years like
everyone wants to live large and have
this flashy lifestyle but they still
want to get a nice sleep and and and
have time for you know hobbies and stuff
if you really want to change your life
work is everything and that's all it is
for years for absolute years before you
even start to think about buying a Lambo
and flexing on Instagram people are got
it all backwards nowadays we can rest in
our
40s I mean I tell myself that and then
Shooters over here still just hustling
so yeah mans yeah maybe I'm trying to
scale back a it brother I am it's just I
got a lot of people rely on me and I
like taking care of them and I like what
I do I'm proud of what I do in many
different areas so it's It's Tricky man
and being busy is a blessing from Allah
100% 100% I would still I would like a
few more hours in the day oh if we could
do like a 28 hour day that'd be great
ald you'd be wanting 32 if we had 28
hours we'll see but yeah I I I don't
need to be busy I'm not the sort of guy
who prides himself on being busy I'm
trying to simplify my life so I have
more time for Arabic study more time for
just spending time with the boys as well
I really value it I really value those
adventures with the lads I really I view
them as some of the most valuable hours
I get to spend on this planet when when
you were out there with your boys doing
you know masculine stuff whether it's
shooting which I think every man should
should learn we can talk about these
sorts of things if you want the
motorbike trips you know that the the
hikes out in the middle of the
Wilderness all this sort of stuff I
think it's really important I really do
yeah 100% um I used to know one guy who
who used to say we rest when we're dead
so aldah something that's a real thing
the ultra high ultra high net worth
individuals I know they're really
successful people they're on it all the
time because every every every minute is
turned into something amazing and so
they literally will rest when they're
dead and the West is no no after after A
Hard Day's Work you need to relax after
the week you need to have a weekend what
weekend I haven't had a weekend in years
what holiday I haven't had a holiday in
years the longest I've gone in the last
13 years without checking my phone was 2
days when I was on an island in
Nicaragua which had no cell phone what
weekend there's no such thing and and
the people at the top that's how they're
living so if you want to get to the
people at top you're competing with the
people at the top you need to get to
that level of output there's no weekends
there's no holidays there's no days off
there you're here to to conquer that's
what you're about Tates embody that
quite well and being around them helped
me pick up my frequency where I could
just work and train endlessly as well
with at least one proper night sleep a
week that's important I think the more
that I go on this journey I won't lie in
the beginning it was uh wanting to have
more money so that I can do all the
things that I couldn't do throughout my
entire life but now it's like I just I
just want what you said you know I want
the simple things in life and I want the
luxury of having the time to be able to
invest into learning more about Islam
getting closer to Allah y awesome here
we go let's go that's it boom cuz
where's where's the sponsorship red bu
come on bro we have never till this day
W Allah I swear by as my witness we've
never hit the 4-Hour mark on a podcast
okay cool the one with you last time was
the guest world record 3 hours 6 minutes
we've never done worse so today we have
to hit 4 hours inshallah Let's Do It
Let's Do It I think we will easily what
time is it right now I love it guys time
is it it's 2 2 a.m. 2:30 a.m. no no no
no it's it's 4 and a half hours fuder
isn't that far away actually yeah oh
My5 minutes wow cool the challenge the
challenge is to keep high quality
content that's true inshallah we're
going to H hit eight hours inshallah
that's the goal things we do for you
watch the dawn come up so this being
said you know in a sorry do you have a
question yeah actually I want to ask
about men being trained I've always
wanted to learn how you know to shoot
guns to shoot a rifle I'm in Canada you
need like like all these licenses and
all this garbage just to be able to go
to a range so Communists don't like guns
in the hands of the people yeah why is
that well because it's a threat
Communists communism is about complete
control of the masses right yeah and so
obviously you want people knowing how to
you know shoot is not communism oh yes
it is is it you really that's as far as
we're going to go on I think Canada's
more communist than China bro if you
want to break it down
objectively what a mess communism with a
sprinkling of degeneracy Canada's a mess
yeah put a nice little Rainbow on it it
doesn't seem like a anym just it's more
it's more masked China is more like BR
about it on like the Forefront Canada is
more like oh we want to be inclusive so
you have to say these things you can't
say these complete thought police
control committed thought thought Crime
After to the you know after to the
goolag I think every man has in them the
inherent desire to be a warrior cuz it's
natural right what do animals do out in
the wild what do young young animals do
like they they wrestle what what the you
know in many societies around the world
and again throughout history what did
the young men do they trained in in how
to fight because they needed to to stay
alive now we don't need that in the west
hamdulillah you know in developed
countries like safe countries but it's
still in us to train in the Warrior arts
and that's why it feels so good man at
the end of a a solid range day you sleep
so deeply I swear your testosterone goes
up
like it's CU you're doing what we're
meant to do now it used to be sticks
then it was swords and you know then it
was bows and arrows the current platform
with which we learn the warrior Arts is
is weapons is firearms and so I think
it's not only is it your your right as a
man I think it's your duty to know the
current day Warrior Arts now I don't
condone joining the military again
because the vast majority of Wars are
generated on false pretenses and purely
exist to serve that you know endless war
military-industrial complex anyone with
a basic geopolitical understanding sees
that clearly for what it is but I think
wanting to be a prepared civilian is a
very Noble thing and I think it's
something everyone should put effort
into so for those who are wanting to
learn how to shoot and and don't have
access to to weapons get yourself some
Airsoft you know the the the you know
they shoot those little pellets Airsoft
weapons and practice your dry firing
practice your draw practice your mag
changes on a rifle practice your high
ready low ready all these sorts of
things you can develop a certain level
of Competency without real weapons and
then from there travel to somewhere
where you can do some Dynamic training
in a completely safe and professional
and certified training facility there's
a lot of them in America where you can
learn you know good competent
selfdefense tactics with weapons you
know how to clear your house how to
respond if there's an intruder how to
deal with you know vehicle hijacking all
these sorts of things now I I don't want
to be in any more gunfights in the rest
of my life thank you very much it's okay
you know I don't need that um but you
better believe I still maintain that you
know currency with with you know the the
various weapon systems various platforms
that that are out there um people say
what's your favorite weapon it's like
whatever I can get that works you in the
countries that I that I operate in but
it's I think it's every man's duty to
know how to defend himself with a weapon
and it's a deeply fulfilling thing to do
so because deep in our in our DNA as men
deep in our you know in the chemicals
you know the hormones running through
our blood that of testosterone we want
to know how to be Warriors so I I I
think every man should prioritize that
and know how to shoot move communicate
work as a group you know the basic
tactics shoot the shooting is the easy
part really it's not that hard to learn
how to shoot with a decent level of
proficiency you know you learn the
Marksmanship principles you know get
your grip and stance right it's not that
hard the challenge is the the the move
communicate piece the working as a team
you know small unit tactics knowing how
to clear rooms how to keep each other
safe how how to keep a level head when
you're in a situation that that goes
connetic where you have people shooting
back at you you can develop that
capability you can build those neural
Pathways that you rely on in a gunfight
through force on Force training through
you know um using simunition where
you're shooting marking rounds you can
go into simulation training with
professionals again there's a lot of
places in the US one of my companies you
know offers these sorts of these sorts
of services where you can get in
simulated gunfights to understand how to
how to keep your a level head and how to
communicate clearly and keep that
awareness so you're not flagging your
buddies and so on th those are the
skills you want to work on not just how
well can I knock down all those targets
you want to get some force on Force
training with the use of simunition
working as a team and exposing yourself
to the stress of an actual gunfight
that's what matters more than how fast
your draw is you know that that's the
training that everyone should seek to to
find again there's a lot of it in the
States you know and and there are other
um certified you know risk-managed
training companies and and Facilities
out there you just search for force on
Force training that that's what everyone
should be aiming for for this it's crazy
this is the first time I'm hearing of
this like I didn't know this was a thing
I'm going to have to drive over the
Border Niagara Falls and find some place
there inshallah so how how important is
conditioning your body let's say
someone's like you know I want to train
my body can get a little more muscle and
maybe train learn how to fight before I
pick up a weapon interesting I think
they different things I mean look if
you're talking purely from the
perspective of personal security ideally
you shouldn't have to have a weapon or
punch anybody cuzz there are many
different um opportunities you had to
see a threat coming and to take evasive
action for example if you are
situationally aware and situational
awareness is one of the key tools you
have within your personal security
Arsenal you'd be able to pick that
somebody is planning to hurt you like
the vast majority of crimes follow
what's known as the Hostile threat cycle
or the Hostile attack cycle there's
pre-attack
surveillance then then then they'll have
to you know Bridge the distance and then
you you you should be able to see some
intent on them if you understand that
the vast majority of crimes are getting
involved some preparation and you can
see these things coming and you know how
to act for example if someone's going to
mug you you think they're just going to
walk up to you randomly they're going to
watch you for a bit is this guy a hard
target is he on his phone you know is he
obviously a tourist is he got displays
of wealth there is going to be that pre
attack surveillance but if you are the
sort of person who has that level of
situational awarness where the second
something is off you can pick that
person's intent or you can pick that
they''re been trained they're positioned
in a room in a certain way that shows
that they they've been trained or
they've got that their fast eyes which
shows you know higher than normal level
of situational awareness is it a trained
individual is it a criminal element with
some intent when you learn to pick these
things you're not going to have to draw
your gun within body I I did executive
protection for years and manag manag
teams all around the world including in
high threat environments if you have to
pull your weapon out as a bodyguard
you've already made a series of mistakes
and the same principle can apply to
personal security you should live in a
certain way where you know your house is
secure that's a lot more important than
how you run a gun you should be very
careful of who you let into your house
the vast majority of crimes involving
residences involve people who are known
to you that's it's a given fact it's
it's always the cleanest cousin or
something like it's just it's just a
thing it's it's a yeah the sound it's a
real thing if you have very high level
of situational awareness so you can see
threats coming if you practice risk
avoidance certain areas of town at
certain times of the day I shouldn't go
to when you're traveling if you do a bit
of you know go to one of the government
travel websites um the Australian one is
smart
travel.gov Au the US one is um oh what
is it anyway just put US government
travel advice read about the country
before you go to it go and go to you
know don't gatch taxes pay a little
extra to have the hotel Center car for
you these little things when you're in a
new city if you don't have someone who
has that local knowledge you can brief
you on the city go and talk to the
consur get a map out where are the bad
areas of town how are tourists being
affected increase your awareness of the
threat environment before you go
somewhere do all these things you you
don't need to fight or
shoot that's what you should focus on if
you want to become personally secure but
having said that it's very satisfying to
learn how to fight and shoot and every
man should how are you going to be a
role model to your son if you don't know
how to throw down if you need to how are
you going to role model to your daughter
the sort of man she should look for in a
husband if you don't know how to protect
your own people you know yes we live in
a society with laws but you can't you're
going to rely on others the police for
your own personal security and that of
your family so I think you need to these
things but back to your question running
a gun is very different to to to
fighting and fighting in the ring is
very different to to fighting in the
street but I think ideally every man
should have have a foundation in
Striking whether it's boxing or Muay
Thai I think you should throw in a
little bit of of grappling because a lot
of street fights involve grabbing and
that that that's you know Judo or
Jiu-Jitsu not that you want to go on the
ground in a fight you get your head
stomped on um I think ideally you've
done a bit of defense against edged
weapons so something like Krav magar but
again you need to know how to fight
before you actually do that so you can
know how to deal with someone coming at
you to at least limit the damage if
someone comes at you with a knife even
with the best training you're going to
get cut you just want to you want to try
and limit where you get cut so you leak
less um ideally you have that foundation
and from there you learn how to shoot if
relevant like if you're living here in
the UAE you don't need to learn how to
shoot do it because you want to practice
the warrior arts and feel good as a man
you know but if you're living in
somewhere like the US man if I was
living in the US I would have to carry
all the time I would have to i' need to
if other if threat elements are out
there if threat actors are out there and
they are carrying you need to carry
otherwise how do you respond you you're
going to Kung Fu them when they put a
rifle in your face you so I think keep
keep Balan stay commensurate you know if
you're living in a very safe country
with no weapons you don't really need to
know how to run a gun focus on on
fighting with your hands you know for
General Health but really if if you take
personal security seriously fighting and
shooting are Last Resorts which you
should not have to use you should have a
a full gamut of strategies and practices
that that limit your exposure to risk or
enable you to act before the threat
manifests well before you need to get
physical that's the honest answer but
Everyone likes to fight and shoot so
yeah embrace it go with it yeah no I
appreciate the answer because it's it's
a lot deeper than just oh you know how
to throw hands it's like it's
situational awareness like special
awareness even we like for the longest
of time when I was in the military um I
took the unarmed combat stuff really
seriously so my my my background was was
I I I did some ground fighting again it
was all focused on being capable not at
a sport but in in hand to hand in a
military situation it was a big part of
my life I took it really seriously for
years even then at the peak of my
training and and I was decent like I was
I was about it if I was in a if I found
myself in a dark alley and someone
pulled a knife and said give me a wallet
I'd give him my wallet how do I know if
he hasn't got a mate with a pistol
behind him how do I know that there
isn't Five Guys around the corner who
going to come out and all night knife me
what a wallet or a watch which I can pay
for with money so even if you have that
height level of skill your mindset
should still be all right going to bring
my wallet out slowly now I'm going to
give it to you brother I don't want any
problem I'm a family man I don't want
any trouble here's my wallet I'm going
to drop it over there there you go it's
yours and it's run that is even if
you're highly skilled that is the route
you should take not not wanting to put
hands on someone so you beat one guy
he's got he's going to have mates you
know like man I I I have mates who' have
been involved in knife crime you're
worried about disease risk you're
worried about all sorts of things it's
not worth it so even though it's great
to know how to shoot and and fight and
all these things even if you are highly
trained your mindset should still be hey
man take it's my fault for putting
myself in a situation where someone can
draw a knife on me in a dark alley guess
what you've earned the watch you've
earned the wallet or if if you're not
prepared to give something away don't
wear it on you like this this is the
honest approach to personal security
it's not wanting to be that guy who can
oh I'm going to disarm him and I'm going
to bash him and
man life ends quickly these meat sacks
that we live in are very delicate you
should you should do everything you can
to avoid needing to use those skills
even though it's very healthy as a man
to develop and maintain those skills wow
the more I learn the more I realize I
don't know anything man crazy I mean
risk avoidance is is a pretty good
approach don't be in dangerous
situations is probably the best
approach like don't if you can afford to
not live in a dangerous area don't live
in a dangerous area that's much better
than having a shotgun in your house and
knowing how to clear rooms if an
intruder comes in just don't be there
risk if you can't afford to live in a
non dangerous area though then be very
informed about what's happening to you
know the local crimes monitor them
carefully and live your life accordingly
if crime spikes at night then do you
need to leave the house at night that's
true you know simp this being said what
would you say would be three just three
of the top strengths of our podcast that
you've witnessed us for strength
strengths of our podcast your podcast
interesting um strengths I think you
guys have a good dynamic in that
um you're good at each of you bringing
your own strengths asking your own
questions so there's good flow um I
think number two would be your intent I
think it's beautiful the way you pray
before you start and your intent is that
of of daah and and helping people as
opposed to hey I want clicks I want
followers I want likes man people
chasing CL it's embarrassing um
and I think the fact that you guys are
Global I think that's really important I
think the future of podcasting is not
sitting in your room zooming people or
or streaming it's getting out there it's
getting that behind the-scenes footage
if I were you I'd mix in behind the
scenes footage of your dubby trip into
podcasts I'd make it an episode I'd make
it interesting I think everyone nowadays
has a podcast where they're sitting
talking what's next the what's next is
being out in the world being different
places getting to know somebody you know
behind the camera and and including that
the behind the scenes things bringing in
your personalities again a lot of people
don't realize what made the UFC at one
point and if you there's documentaries
on this the UFC as an organization
wasn't doing that well what made it
popular was The Ultimate Fighter the
reality TV program that showed the drama
showed the personality showed the
struggle that went into Fighters that's
where UFC went we've seen recently a
very strong increase in fans and and and
those who are interested in Formula 1 do
you know why that Netflix series race to
survive that showed the drama showed the
struggle showed the personalities behind
the scenes now all of a sudden everyone
loves F1 again I think the same thing
can be said with podcasts it needs to be
more than just hey here's four polished
guys sitting you need to show show
you're on the plane talk about the
struggle to get here talk about your
plans talk about your personalities show
behind the scenes do podcasts in
different situations walking down the
street you know going to the mused you
know whatever you can do that's
different and shows more interactivity I
think is is the way to take it forward
you guys are already doing that well by
being Global and going out to people I
think that's the future the more the
more different situations and different
stories and and Adventures to get there
and Adventures back showing your
personality showing your struggle to me
that would take this to the next level
means a lot from someone of your caliber
bro thank you bro I don't know much
about podcast though to be fair aldah
number two what would be three things
that we can all improve on as a
collective I I think the art to again as
somebody who used to question people for
a living you know in in a appropriate
ways of course
is open questions that are well thought
out and that are tailored to the person
you're asking the question of is very
powerful I mean your your your goal is
to get people talking in interesting
ways to open up you mentioned with Tam
he was saying things he hadn't said
before you know was really powerful
really impactful inshallah I would put
really focused effort into profiling
someone a little bit who's this person
about what are their belief systems what
are their challenges what are their
passions and then I would build
questions based on that to best elicit
that free flowing raw data dump of
insight and experience or whatever they
have to offer so I do a bit of a
profiling on everyone before you talk to
them and come up with some really open
as in you know open-ended intelligent
questions to really get them dropping
the insights they can drop because for
example with me I'm I'm not the sort of
person naturally is going to sit there
and say interesting things I'm not built
for this whole I don't feel the need to
constantly self-promote I'm naturally a
bit of a private person it takes good
questions to get me talking so you guys
do that well I think give that even more
Focus profile each individual and come
up with really targeted questions to
best let them bring out the value they
have to share that's one thing I do
that's u in terms of next
um keep going global guys just just keep
going all around the world and again if
you need more funding funding is
something that can be obtained like if
if it's a money problem then it's not a
problem right like money is something
you can solve so I'd keep coming up with
plans initiatives and then get backing
do do what any other business does any
other brand does this is what we've done
this is what we plan to do this is what
the ask is you will find backers to get
you out there especially when they see
the ROI on on on the daa that you're
doing so i' I'd be more ambitious in
terms of plans and initiatives and then
seeking backing for that and you've got
my number you know like it's it's not
like you need to go and build some
relationship of course man least I could
do brother at least I could appreciate
you guys I'm glad you're here it's
awesome number three um number three
what could you guys do better
could be anything even off camera that
you know just based on our
Communications things you've picked up
on us by now yeah I think part of the
reason why I mean again I'll refer to
someone who's the master of this space
knowing that I'm I'm not a social media
or podcast guy part of the reason why
Tate is so impactful is he lives what
he's talking about he is he talks about
being mentally mentally resilient he
shows that man I was in the room when he
lost he lost his Banks he lost his
Instagram he lost his payment processes
he lost his website hosting everything
unfazed genuinely didn't care lost
everything didn't care right we got work
to do like he he talks he walks what he
talks I think you guys
should refine exactly what is your
message what is your key message to the
youth so in the same way any any company
or any brand here's our company ethos
here's what we stand for have you guys
sat around and strategized what you
really are about what are you here for
what are the key impacts you want to
have on people have you written down
your core messages and your core your
core ethos that drives you I'd do that
and then i' I'd live to it i' I'd very
openly and obviously be the guy who is
walking what he talks because that's
what Tate does so well so if you are all
about being disciplined and and hustling
and being fit then show your yourselves
doing that Tate shows himself being a
weapon of a man physically he shows his
training he shows his boxing you know he
he shows his Success Through endless
buying of vehicles but I mean hey it's
something he enjoy and that fuels him to
keep going he is showing the benefits of
living by what he preaches and I think
I'd like to see you guys doing that even
more what are your key messages what is
the key impact you're looking to have on
on what demographics you know I'd say
it's predominantly young Muslim men or
those considering Islam and and not even
just young as well like any any any
Muslim men and perhaps sisters as well
what are the key messages you want them
to live by and then show yourselves
living true to it that's that's what I'd
do cuz that that's what has made Tate so
powerful when you look at Tate you can
see what Tate is talking about Works cuz
he embodies it so I I'd look to I'd look
to replicate
that mean thank you so much cool very
cool awesome would you have any guests
in mind that you really anticipate on
our podcast I think T would be great
inah that
happens um both yeah indeed wow that'll
be interesting um that would be really
cool it'd be great to have a discussion
with Tristan that man knows his history
oh yeah he actually knows his Islamic
history pretty well too and Tristan Tate
has an intellect a lot of people don't
realize CU he's you know he's such an
Adonis looking figure they just assume
he doesn't have the brain on him he has
he can talk history I mean I was
remember I was at a gathering with him
and there was an Indian Chap and they
talked for like 2 and 1 half hours about
Indian history man I what I know about
Indian history is like maybe 2 minutes
and this Indian gu is just looking at
him like how is he doing this he knows
more about my history in my country than
I do like Tristan hears stuff and it
just sticks in his head so it' be very
interesting to have a podcast with him
um in terms of other
people I'm not sure guys again I'm not
really a big social media person to be
honest I I I yes I'm on social media but
my focus is the physical world and
and this space not the not the social
space but uh again I'd sit down I'd
strategize what are you about what's the
key output that like what is what is
your goal what what is it exactly that
what in 5 years what do you want to have
achieved and then a reverse engineer
from there just look at yourselves as a
brand as a business and get really like
do a SWAT analysis if you will have a
one-ear plan have a 2-year plan talk
about how much funding you need how much
time you need to devote to it map it out
and make it happen like tape talks about
this you need a plan everyone wants to
be big and do well what's your plan how
are you going to execute it everyone has
ideas everyone has motivations everyone
wants what's your plan and how you going
to execute I'd just get really specific
about that I really would like you would
with building any other business or
building any other
brand I do it amazing all right thank
you so much should we ask about our logo
yeah honestly man you guys we we got to
show you this awesome I want to give a
quick shout out to uh brother Ahmed Ben
shba who very his opinion on he gave his
opinion op um but you know that's why
we've been asking many brothers their
opinion and just seeing what they think
so this is our logo U let me
see I cannot see this oh will you had
the same exact
reaction let's
see so this is our logo for the three
Muslims okay I like it give us the most
constructive feedback that you can give
I see look it's aesthetically very
pleasing the way it flows like that I
see the symbology that that of that of
um you know religious structures I'd
like more personality in it is it too
corporate it is rather corporate guys
yeah I'd like to see more personality
and more of view in that that looks like
a designer has gone and done something
very nice as as opposed to how would you
refine that or even completely like if
you had any other ideas again I think
you guys need to sit down and find
exactly what you're about exactly what
you're trying to achieve like each one
of you should have a clear area value ad
that you have to bring you know like we
have a revert so you have an extra you
know input there obviously your Arabic
is quite strong as is your knowledge of
the scriptures your value there you've
also got a lot of hadiths to refer to
like you guys need to you know if you're
if you're you're Avengers if you're
Power Rangers what what color are you
what are you you know what what do you
do what what what weapon system do you
have do you have the nunchucks or do you
have the uh the long stick thing Define
exactly what you are what your roles are
and what are you here to do and map it
out and again if you want funding man we
can get funding that's not that's not a
big deal if you have a clear plan and a
clear if you contribute to this this is
what we will achieve then funding will
happen that's not the problem that's not
trust me if if there's a problem that
can be solved by money it's not a
problem you know certain problems such
as health issues or death of a loveed
one that that's a problem you can't fix
it with money money issues are not not a
problem so yeah map it out guys what is
your mission statement what is your
oneyear plan what is your threeyear plan
where's that Clarity what are you doing
view yourselves as a business that you
need to grow and obviously you're not
chasing that cash you're chasing
something a lot more significant but why
not apply the principles of business
which work be my two we got some work to
do guys you guys you guys need a
strategy day really do yeah inallah
awesome how often should we me to
strategize yeah um I mean that should be
written in as well do you guys live in
different cities right we do yeah
different countries different countries
continents I looked I mean maybe that
comes in the Str in 2 years we all want
to be living in the UAE maybe maybe
that's part of it seriously map these
things out like again you think someone
like Tate went from ghetto housing to to
to Bugattis by accident you know there's
clear plans and and same with me for the
longest of time I had different
different you know this year I want to
be doing this this year I want to be
doing this I'm now at the point where I
just don't have plans and every day is
just a blur of positivity but for the
longest of time I had very clear
business strategy type structure and
approach and kpis and and goals to hit
for my life you got to be very conscious
and you got to have that plan then you
got to execute that's the key thing man
you got to do every Everyone's an
overthinking nowadays everyone has these
big plans you got to do the successful
business people that I know they don't
sit around thinking they do they don't
they don't like thinking they you have
to force them to strategize like yeah
but we want to do no no sit we're going
to have a corporate Workshop we're going
to strategize yeah but we want to do
that's what it's all about getting out
there and doing it and that's what I've
tried to teach my son as well I mean I
think my approach to Parenting is a is a
little unconventional from a very early
age I was talking about International
Commerce and and supply chain and and
and all these different things you know
the banking system with my my son I
think I started talking about these
things when he was like five or six to
to unlock that Curiosity and to let him
know and also with my daughter as well
the complexity of the world that they
live in and to teach them that which
school doesn't teach them I think it's
super important all parents should teach
their kids you know the basics of
business and of strategy and of personal
finance and you know business related
finance and how how the monetary system
works and all these different things um
man you should have seen like my my
8-year-old son when he found out about
taxation rates in Sweden he's like over
50% but Dad how can they do that I'm
like they're the government son they can
do whatever they want he's like yeah but
how are they allowed to do that 50%
that's too much I'm like I agree with
you son and welcome to uh to being
antisocial to exactly for real U but I I
I think that there's there's something
that the elite families know and they
they do quite well is is they run their
lives like businesses and I think it's
up to us to to teach that to to our kids
you can change your life if you want to
you're just going to have to a very
conscious and structured approach yeah
and man I tell you it's a crime how
poorly schools equipped people with
financial understanding yeah it's just
disgusting but it's by Design right man
the one time I realized school was
broken taking my kid to school in
deby and at a certain age you just take
him in the classroom but I think it was
maybe year two onwards they gathering
this in in the quad area This Grass area
there's a whistle that blows not unlike
a factory whistle they all have to line
up and they are led by their teachers
into their classroom why why don't they
just go to the classroom like when they
were younger cuz they're being trained
to be Factory workers man that's what
the school system does it trains you to
literally be a cog in the machine so I
think it's the duty of every parent
can't even take a slash without putting
your hands up for for real man there a
duty of every parent to teach your kids
how to appropriately question authority
how to negotiate how to you know
understand how businesses are built how
to understand how to manage staff all
these different things like you have to
teach your kids this even if you're not
at the point where you're running
businesses yourself it is your duty as
your parent as a parent to teach your
kids the skills that you know children
from Elite families grow up around they
grow up around their families running
businesses they learn this stuff by
default so with that being said do you
have your children being homeschooled
like would you rather do this or it's a
funny one I think my Approach is a
school system that is is halal which we
see in this part of the world that's my
preference because I think schooling
isn't so much I mean look you need to
you can argue that what you're learning
in school helps you build the muscle
that is learning you you at school you
might not learn what's useful but you do
learn how to learn so you can argue that
that's useful I also think school is
useful predominantly for navigating the
social landscape that you don't
necessarily get with homeschooling so I
I think it's useful but I genuinely
believe what my son when he moves to me
in inshah in a year and ideally you know
my daughter could move over here at some
point too which means bringing um um my
ex and her current family over here
which I'm very happy to support I love
both my kids to be here um I'm working
hard to be able to afford such things
reward you bro thank you brother but um
ideally genuinely I believe this what
what I teach my kids outside of school
will be more useful to their life than
what they learn in school I'll build
their characters I'll expose them to
healthy amounts of risk I'll teach them
I teach them about business all these
different things so yes do school learn
social you know navigation learn the
politics involved of having to deal with
a nasty teacher and so on because that
replicates the real world right but when
they are with me that's when we really
teach them these are the skills that're
going to serve you well in life this is
the understanding that you need to
succeed in life I mean have you noticed
why is tax not taught in
schools every single successful
businessman I know spends a significant
amount of their waking hours dealing
with tax and how to minimize tax or how
to pay you know how how to structure
things so that they are tax optimized
that's never touched in school maybe
because they don't want you to be tax
optimized they don't yeah exactly this
is the thing right there it is so it is
it's the duty of every parent to teach
our kids that which school doesn't teach
and the majority of that is all things
business and all things Finance so do
you think that it would be enough if
your kids had let's say several close
friends from families that you knew
right and that was their social
environment because realistically
speaking let's let's think about real
life now like once the person leaves
College University or just High School
in general actually I don't know if they
have high school in this part of the
world but just school right they leave
school they don't have as much friends
the friends that they have it just
Narrows down true and then it's like you
have three to six MH mhm three to six
close I think that's more natural
definitely I've met some kids who are
homeschooled schooled who are remarkably
more advanced than those who are in
school cuz you get more one-onone with
who's teaching you right so I see the
value in it I um I just haven't
considered it as a viable option I I I
don't have the time personally I see you
on that but yeah I think it's a noble
thing to do if you have the time as a
parent to to school your children uh
they will invariably become a lot more
involved in terms of their their
knowledge and their capabilities cuz
they got that you know that more
concentrated Focus one teacher in 25
kids is is inferior to you know one in
one and one and two yeah I just think to
myself like imagine the benefit imagine
your kid you teach them exactly what
they need and by the time they're 15 if
you do it all right they could have all
these skills plus they can have the
social skills as well and they're
essentially 15 20 if not 30 years ahead
of every single person they makes sense
if you have the bandwidth if you have
the energy definitely but uh man raising
kids is is is challenging that Lo
homeschooling as well and businesses and
and and in an Ideal World I think it's a
very Noble thing to do definitely
definitely definitely for sure do you
have any other par you know parenting
tips I think one of the things that I
taught my kids which I think has paid
off very well was at an early age I
taught them you have the right to choose
your own belief systems in this world
and there are many different entities
and individuals out there who are going
to try and push belief systems on you
whether that's a teacher pushing a
certain alphabet agenda whether that's
advertising campaigns trying to get you
to buy their products whether that's
that's Western culture trying to get you
you know to sexualize yourself or you
know whatever degeneracy is being pushed
and I've made it clear to both of them
you are the ultimate decider about what
you believe in life don't let anyone
push their beliefs on you and watch out
for people who are pushing their beliefs
on you to the point now where my son
even at an early age he he noticed he's
going through Netflix he's like Dad
there's a girl power section here but
there's no boy Power section he notices
as a young man I'm and of course I'm not
going to tell him my I'm not going to
put a belief on him I say why do you
think that is and he says well Dad I see
it in all the movies all the the girls
are strong and all the guys are a bit
stupid and I say okay why do you think
that is well is they're trying to push
up women it's from a young man and and I
say okay and is that a good thing or bad
he says well yeah it's I guess it's a
good thing but why are they pushing down
men why are they pushing down boys oh
let's discuss that you know there was a
thing called feminism that came in and
now it's all about Pro women and it
makes sense because you know things need
to be balanced out now perhaps it's gone
over the top and it's a bit you know
it's Pro women and anti-men in some of
the man the amount of times in kids
movies where you see one woman beating
up five men it's it's all the time how
often in movies do you see a man beating
a woman you don't and good I don't want
to see that sort of thing but man just
about every movie nowadays there's a
woman beating up a buncher man it's just
standard you know like that Atomic
blonde film you got a woman who weighs
all of 55 kilos beating up 10 Russian
Mobsters I'm sorry what but it's
everywhere it's nonsense but but letting
encouraging your children to see that
many different individuals entities they
have agendas and they want to push that
on you and they want to influence your
belief systems in ways that won't
necessarily benefit you they'll benefit
them and you need to be conscious of
that at an early age that's something
both of my kids have which I'm quite
proud of if you will as a parent but I
think the main thing with parenting
isn't necessarily the words you say or
or or you know what you try and
Implement it's the role modeling the
most powerful thing you can do as a
parent is role model this motorbike
right here I bought that immediately
after I divorced and I I didn't do it so
much for the motorbike I did it for my
kids to see you know Dad's all right
dad's you know he's he's he's an
adventurous guy he's having a good life
cuz I was really down I was really
hurting through divorce was very
difficult and and you know not having my
kids in my life all my all the time hurt
me a lot and that that's when they were
still in the same country but I wanted
to buy the motorbike to say you know
what look that Dad was obviously hurting
you know that they'd seen me upset but
he's still out there he's riding a bike
he's taking us on the bike he's having
fun you know Dad's cool role modeling
the sort of man you want your son to
become and the sort of man you want your
daughter to choose as a future husband
that's super important more important
than the words or you know the the sort
of parenting techniques you apply you
must role model being a powerful
masculine Noble hardworking upstanding
virtuous man that's the key that your
your your kids see wow this guy is my
hero I want to be like that or in the
case of a daughter that's a good man I
know what I should look for what I
deserve as a man U some other things
that I'll say in terms of my son I I'm
quite firm on him and that I've pushed
him towards risk you know he's boxing
and so on he loves it now but at the
start was a bit of a push I I I I often
you know I push him in terms of his
understanding and intellect and I I
challenge him a fair bit I challenge my
daughter but in a different way I'm a
lot more gentle with her um I I think
it's okay to to teach or to to raise
kids differently I think it's a very
important thing but the one thing that I
do with my son is I'm aware of the fact
that the validation from his dad is very
important I don't overg give it but I
definitely when he does well I give it
son at the end of the day I'm proud of
you you you know I'll say when we're
going to bed you did well today I want
you have a nice deep sleep you know I'm
really proud of who you are and who
you're becoming as a young man you know
give that praise cuz that's what Sons
want now with my daughter she doesn't
necessarily want praise she wants Focus
like a lot of women grow up with these
daddy issues not cuz their dad didn't
love them because their dad wasn't
present dad was invariably busy with
work but as a young you know mind a
young girl she's viewed dad isn't
present dad doesn't love me I don't
deserve love from the masculine then she
goes and gets unhealthy relationships
and she grows grows up to this day no
matter how important the meeting I'm in
if I get a little ping from from my
daughter cuz she has the papa iPad she
can write to me I will answer that
excuse me I need to take this throughout
her entire life anytime she wanted to
talk to her dad whether she was living
in the same country as me or now in
another country I'm present for her so
as if you're raising a daughter give her
that presence not so much gifts or
praise just be present and fully
attentive on her that's what she's
looking for that's your best way to help
her avoid those daddy issues that's the
best way to help her feel on a deep
level she deserves to be loved by the
masculine so that when she grows up and
finds a husband that masculine is
someone who loves her because again
we're not as adults we're not attracted
to what's healthy we're attracted to
what's familiar if you have an unhealthy
relationship with your mom you're going
to go and get yourself an unhealthy
relationship with a woman CU that's
what's familiar same same with dirty
issues all these sorts of things so you
must give that full presence and it's
difficult as a busy man but you must
give that full presence uh especially to
to your daughter um I also have a bunch
I mean I don't know how deep you want to
go into parenting but I have a bunch of
different things that I brought in for
example from the earliest of age I'd say
at the end of the day we all say three
things that we're grateful for I may
have mentioned this on our last podcast
I'm not sure but we we we say and to the
point now my kids will say can I go
first Papa it's and we say three things
we're grateful for in the day and to me
that's that's I'm I'm I'm implementing
gratitude as a default setting to keep
them grounded cuz man like my my my
8-year-old daughter has flown first
class this is tricky right you got to
keep them grounded It's Tricky and so
the way I do that is by this gra
gratitude practice you you want to give
to your kids but you also want to keep
them them grateful and grounded and
another thing I did as a very early uh
early age with my kids is I do those CH
your Ro adventure stories and i' bring a
lot of archetypes for example and to
actually when you meet my son inshah I
want you to say to him amadas what do
you do when life gets tough what do you
do when it's difficult he will instantly
reply you keep going it's deep in him at
an early age because what we do is we do
stories where it's Sayes you need to
climb up that mountain and fight that
dragon and get that gold or you know
fight that dragon and save the Village
but you're you're walking up the
mountain to get him your legs are tied
what do you do keep going Papa all right
now you're fighting the dragon your arms
are getting tied you just want to give
up what do you do keep going Papa so at
that early age I put in that persistence
piece and again what do we see in
successful people around the world they
have incredible persistence they may not
be the smartest they may not be you know
but they have that persistence that's
key so the traits that you want to see
in your children you can in a positive
way you can program that into them they
have very soft minds but again Ask him
ask and another thing ask my son Hey cuz
now that he's a bit older and you know
they're talking about girls in school
and so on ask my son I'm a are you going
to you know are you are you going to
chase women he will instantly reply no
I'm going to chase success and then the
women will chase me wow now you may not
approve of that as a parent but that's
deep in his mind now and he knows I need
to work on myself as a man and then I'll
be able to manifest a positive
relationship I don't need to be going
and chasing girls like every all my
friends are doing and we you know
especially when he hits teenage years
we'll be doing you can get these
messages in early it's it's incredible
sculpting these these these young humans
and watching them grow it's
beautiful that's that's amazing that's
all amazing may Allah bless you and your
family immensely it's beautiful to hear
may Allah make us all great parents
Allah it's very inspiring to hear thank
you man I love that bro with shooter we
could just talk all day man yeah
honestly let us know in the comments
guys if you want part three inshallah
it's six month let's do it every 6
months guys fly over
here how we going for time guys should
we wrap it up
and maybe next time we could do a live
as well and we can get some questions in
that be cool
defitely anything else you want to drop
any wisdom last
minute um look I don't pretend to be a
social media guy I don't pretend to
understand you know all this cool this
and that
but if you're utilizing social media to
produce good which you guys are doing
you know da a positive impact if you're
consuming social media in a way that
improves your life I think it's a medium
that's worthwhile um and man I I I
really do believe in your platform I
think it's up to us to make Islam cool
again especially with the youth Islam is
viewed as something that oh it's a chore
it's restrictive there's a lot of
obligations as as a multi-millionaire
with all of the trappings of daa Islam
has added so much value to my life and
if it can add value to my life
somebody's got everything so to speak it
can add value to everyone's life and so
I I really do see the value what you're
doing and I think you we should all keep
trying to make yes you can be successful
and be a good Muslim yes you can live an
amazing exciting life all around the
world and still stay on the dean like I
think the more we can do to to make
Islam cool again and and deliver da on
platforms like this on social media the
better so I think what you guys are
doing is super important and and may
Allah subhana wa tala keep you motivated
and steadfast and project your message
out to as many people as possible cuz
this is the Battleground the social
media Battleground is the is where young
minds are shaped is where people's
belief systems are influenced so the
Battleground that you're fighting in is
a really important one I I really hope
inshallah that it just goes from
strength to strength and your message
gets out there even more insh thank you
so much we're going to strategize I
think that's going to be our goal
inshallah I think that's a great
starting point for us so we're going to
do it amazing brother 6 months if not
before inshallah and maybe maybe we can
do it somewhere else as well guys maybe
we can set up somewhere interesting
maybe we could do it in Saudi inshallah
that would be
cool let our equipment in then yeah I I
can I can help with that that's fine
good get necessary permissions or we
could not do that as
well but yeah let's keep making
interesting let's keep mixing it up
let's honestly let your message needs to
be made entertaining and made cool to
reach as many people as possible let's
think about some ways to do that and
again if funding is required that's easy
that's the easy part the the coming up
with that Vision as to how to make this
most impactful most entertaining most
cool the challenge yeah 100% we're going
to get on that apprciate you guys thanks
for coming us thank you so much for
having us may Allah bless you immensely
allow us to keep doing it and allow you
to keep doing the great work that you're
doing thank to all of viers at home may
Allah bless you all immensely for
watching part one and part two if you
didn't watch part one check it out in
with st tur shooter and we'll see you
guys on the next
one